salut tout le monde si vous voulez louer
le studio sf pour faire votre propre
podcasts ou pour objet d la qualité de
votre podcast c'est possible écrivez
nous à sans filtre podcast at gmail.com
vous venez ici le service et tout
compris vous avez la vidéo vous avez le
son qu'on vous donne suite après votre
enregistrement
yann nicol qui va être là pour vous
servez pour vous accompagner dans cette
aventure
le studio sfr on s'assure que la qualité
était petit mal à tous les niveaux et
puis pour ramener votre projet au niveau
c'est vraiment la bonne chose à faire
alors écrivez-nous savoir plaisir de
vous recevoir ici une production du f
mais elle nous sans filtre le podcast on
parle de ce qu'on veut que nous inviter
dans le perche canton avec madame plan
du yo yo mène cette semaine laissant
filtrer présenté par notre page
piquionne on a un nouveau concept sur
pékin après chaque saut on fait quelque
chose qui s'appelle l'encore moyen de
filtres ou est ce qu on fait juste
débriefer d'impy moins sûr blinken
vinicole en fait on part la nuque elle
aussi sur le podcast convient de faire
fonctionner nos réactions à chaud en
fait sur le podcast fait que c'est comme
une continuité de la conversation
convient d'avoir ou est ce qu on fait
juste dire jazzy un peu sur qu'est ce
qu'on vient de vivre la conversation
qu'est ce qu'on en pense et tout ça fait
que si vous voulez aller là vous
inscrire et inscrivez-vous sur notre
pétillante le lien votre dans la
descente du podcast puis c'est la
meilleure façon nous encourager pour
cancer une bonne communauté somptueux
mais nous rejoindre c'est le fun on
s'amuse oublié sinon cette semaine là on
a reçu grid qui a ri qui a ri de aude et
bien sûr les afriques
c'était sympa c'était pas le fun
vraiment un iceberg en a parlé
si c'était à le tourner c'était quelques
semaines puis si on a parlé beaucoup de
10 du mouvement dans la foulée de la
mode d'ordre flotte des compagnies de
son histoire à lui comment lui vécu le
racisme commun qui ont vécu d'avoir
grandi à montréal
raconter l'histoire de l'immigration de
ses parents qui m'ont littéralement levé
le poils sur les bras pour vrai jour
c'est vraiment important qu'on entende
ce genre d'histoire le pour changer
notre perception des immigrants parce
que cc66 extrêmement difficile et
traumatisant l'impression de tout
quitter pour changer de pays pipe
quand ça m'a vraiment touché cette
histoire le on a parlé bien sûr
d'occupation double petit retour là
dessus petite mise au point qu'ils
consentent et qu'il fonde en temps de ce
puits je suis vraiment belles rencontres
- écoutez le saouler commentaires dans
la description
j'en ai soumis commentaires dans les
commentaires dans la section commentaire
les semaines des ratings sur les
applications audio vous êtes de plus en
plus nombreux à nous écouter en audio
fait que ça lui à tout le monde qu'ils
ont commencé à nous intégrer à leur
routine de 2 comme utah tous les matins
et tous les soirs au jam en faisant de
lavage dans la bouffe
[Musique]
j'ai une anecdote mais c'est peut-être
pas premier jeu vous raconter quand même
j'écoutais j'avais une fréquentation
dans ce temps là puisque je faisais les
midis jazz à ckrl je pense oui oui
j'écoute est juste le jazz parce qu'il y
avait ce qui mettait de la musique
souvent tu parlais très rarement
puis j'ai commencé à devenir un as tu y
avait avec la personne qu'elle
fréquentait pis la toune de jazz unit
placé alors dominique plancke
c'est tout ce qui me passait bon
quelqu'un il sans plus attendre mon
podcast
bonne écoute
[Musique]
tu peux tu peux couper des boutons à
adagio je me trouve quand même bon de
rien coupé parce que je me trouvais
souvent comme certaines choses qu'ils
entendent et hop c'est jusqu'à ma taille
je te revois les temps des petits mots
que j'ai dit constamment à petit jusqu'à
si tu me fais chier mais ou pire les
fois d'après ça arrive pas parce que tu
t'habitues charge et monte au début mais
c'était tout le temps sonne m'agacer
c'est arrivé deux trois fois là qu'elle
met en jeu
j'ai posé des questions plus jamais ton
j'ai eu un blanc pendant 5 secondes ou
que george est vraiment trop tourner ton
époux et moi qui me donne droit à
claques
j'ai le droit seule fois en fait j'ai
coupé ses jours avec moi certainement
invités pour les protéger le parce que
pourquoi nous maintenons mathieu disons
premier pas qui est ce que j'ai fait je
pense que vous devez vous imaginez
qu'ils ont dit des niaiseries puis des
fois jusqu'à ce que moi il ya des
moments là j'ai envoyé par message texte
j'étais quand même est-ce que mathieu
des à l'aise si ça se passe comment
ouais bah oui puis après comme je vous
dis le jour vous allez rencontrer et a
manqué une fois c'est s'il ya une belle
énergie c'est juste que je pense que des
fois dans la vie si tu jamais
nécessairement eu quelqu'un qui te
confronter pâques par rapport à quelque
chose
ben tu veux pouvoir c'est négatif c'est
comme mathieu tient réellement bolger
réellement genre prend la place dans une
pièce pi s'est jamais montré ont voulu
être content lui on va dire naturel fait
qu habituellement c'est quand arriva au
décès le problème qui peut s'il est de
nature et ses mystères ses vedettes
d'être comme ça que j'ai vécu ces mots
j'étais capitaine du rouge et or c'est
quelqu'un qui est effectivement un
leader naturel et les gens ont tendance
à vouloir me suivant ce que je réussis
et puis
tu arrives là même pas tu rencontres
légumes secs en manque et tout était
capitaine de ton équipe de hockey qui
s'était tu étais comme présidente à
clore ce qui est tout était genre les
gokhool au secondaire plus tu te rends
compte que tout le monde ce genre de
gars qui dans cette histoire caisse mais
toi qu'est ce qui était bon la danse que
je trouve ce qu'il t'est arrivé puis tu
l'idée par exemple à la place et parce
que moi j'étais une année que j'ai
enlevé puis tout le monde lit des parts
parole j'en faisais juste par les fortes
et là le premier 15 minutes qu'on était
ensemble autour ici c'est tout des fours
tiré dans la tête de leader dans un
groupe mais j'étais juste comme ça
marchera pas si tu essayes de prendre
plus de place que mathieu qui en train
de monter sur le sofa qui sont en train
de faire des backflips radar maison
c'est juste comme au kg de la personne
plus attentifs ugc de qom l'idée part
c'est ma belle façon d'agir mart une
forte pas si c'est ça peut être ça peut
aider reine des fois là parce que tout
ce temps par paquet de niaiseries dans
une journée et j'ai tellement j'ai
tellement fait de méditation à rodez le
pineau de jeu mais est-ce que tu médites
avant d'être en vie je médite en avant
puis je connaissais les bénéfices mais
je ne faisais pas sur une base régulière
et on dirait que j'ai pas dans le chaos
de la ville vivait cgt faisait neuf à
cinq je travaille 40 ajoute encore à
l'école je faisais du sport
universitaire comme j'étais un malade
pour être une année là que j'ai quatre
cours à l'université 45 heures semaine
de travail entre le casino pis
restauration était tout de nuit fait
qu'après le matin à le réveiller pour
aller à l'école puis en même temps
j'avais des pratiques encore de basket
parce que je venais de revenir à
montréal puis jouait pour concordia dans
l'équipe de basket mais là après genre
cinq mois dans l'équipe c'est commun qui
énonce et ça fait aucun bon sens mais je
sais c'est la face et que c'est tout le
match mais on dirait que sam drive dans
la vie juste de commettre active pour
faire quelque chose si on sait que le
confinement c'est quelque chose qui est
puis au décès quelque chose qui était
vraiment difficile pour moi même et j'ai
commencé à juste
me ressourcer et pc de contrôler mais
nrj puis mes pensées et puis c'est
contraint à flêtre tu dois comprendre
que c'est un monsieur tu travailles ton
cerveau puis deux compris comment tu as
travaillé d'autres musées puis comment
tu t'es ramené à certains points dans ta
vie c'est ce que j'ai compris avec la
méditation c'est que ok toutes les
pensées que j'ai un certain poche
capable de dire non c'est assez je
capable de les compromis compromet
relais c'est seulement que j'irai en
anglais pigiste mais calme et puis tout
à fait positif c'est même sur le thème
adoptive de personnes d'ici que le pays
qui fatalement le métier des des gares
des 1,27 positif à travers toute la
halle espèce de paranoïa qui le jubé des
câbles que je pu créer l'outil de
dépenses est de savoir qui est éliminé
de savoir qu'un mec pas là ton dos
probablement quai des alliances qui se
forme qui est une espèce de gains de
rester sans rien là dedans imaginez j'ai
jamais fait de l'insomnie dans ma vie
j'en ai fait tout à eau des gens tout
les soir parce que non seulement je
pensais à ça la game je suis compétitif
et que j'arrivais dans une game crèche
avec tout le monde mais vous l'avez vu
c'est la boulette que je décoche puis
répétées des cages aboud intéressés
quand je parlais démontre aussi sportif
sur tout comme pour voir la boulette de
jeu web c'était juste drôle mais un
ajout qui s'était qu'avait six
catégories dont voici juste que je suis
pas chaque fois je rentre dans un esprit
de compétition je me dis ok c'est une
chance de me dépasser ce une chance de
m'améliorer et puis en ce moment je suis
dans une game vous ce que c'est
complètement mental ces compléments
relationnel avec tout le monde autour de
toi fait que c'est vraiment important
que j'essaie de le remporter parce que
ça va me rapporter dans le reste de ma
vie dans tout ce que je veux faire en
suède 6 puis qu'est-ce que je me suis
rendu compte que chaque soir j'ai juste
pensé non seulement à comment manoeuvrer
à travers ce jeu là mais si on parle
tout le contexte d'un racisme en ce
moment moi je me suis mis une pression
incroyable de pas être le troc and white
men ou de genre pomme faire tes police
est là pour d'école ici après une
semaine c'était que je voulais être
parfait surtout ce qui arrache dépendant
jeu gptd prépare
alité au sillage c'est juste que mon
pied j'ai de poli je dors bien
cette équipe est ce que peut dépenser
pendant que voulait pas déranger il être
un bon exemple noir en guinée oui parce
que cette question-là genre non offense
pour celui qui étaient là l'an passé
belles années devant moi mais comme s
était dans notre communauté il restait
vraiment blessant parce qu'on est quand
même tu es de toutes les belles
personnes étaient bien qui s'est pointé
qui est fait c'est justement la vie gens
aimant la vie genre comme je suis sûr
que résultat et je suis sûr c'est un
super bon gars pic il super intelligent
pitt est descendu l'afrique doit être
d'abord une bonne brise en tout mais
c'est juste que chaque fois qu'a mettons
la télévision on voit quelqu'un notre
communauté arrivée puis qui se fait se
passe ramasser ou de salaires sont
généralement mais c'est juste difficile
c puis c'est pour ça que beaucoup de
personnes dans mon entourage était comme
crise qui avisera
vas-y puis comme nous on sait que sa
tante fait le bien qui fait le bien pour
nous mais une fois que cela ben j'arrive
en confessionnal avec la paire syngof
confessions à la fin de chaque soirée
puis quelque chose arrive pendant
journée de sa me frustre hitchcock et
qui a ri pensée pour vrai qu'ils ok
magog qui tient au fait si aujourd'hui
mais là j'avais toute la journée pour me
calmer pour me refaire les idées plus
acheter jusqu'à comment ça va passer au
québec de voir le noir frustrer un
certain point qui se présentent aux
professionnels puis qui commença à
bâcher quelqu'un d'autre c'est pour tout
ce qu'ils ont encore un qui ont encore
une certaine j'ai justement c'est un
terrain de ces plots 6 mai puis le genre
c'est un grosse général black me suis
fait reprocher une seule fois de la
saison le club compte keven si vous vous
rappelez bien puis si vous suivez la
saison
si je peux dire et rien que la
production mais à chaque fois qu'il y
avait quelque chose qui voulait montrer
négatif sur moi c'était ce moment là qui
revenant lui plaise ou non tout le temps
tout à tout le temps ça c'est pas propre
à rehausser ses propres eaux chaudes
l'impression le cpie je dis rien c'est
juste propre au show de montrer les
moments négatifs régale ses fautes et
peng d'une certaine façon est ce que toi
dans le processus de vouloir participer
à l'émission est-ce que tu avais le
justin king l'heure de dire je veux
aller
pauvre france tu es tu mènes mais je
vais aller montrer comment comment je
peux être comment je peux représenter la
communauté positivement dans tout c'est
ce que c'était tout le temps en temps
quelqu'un en y allant de 100% institut
goethe et comme je veux même pas parce
que tu as un certain point tu dis tu
peux essayer de passer à travers toutes
les armes et ont jeté dans l'univers
corporatif d'avant j'étais conseil
financier serait rater des étudiants
finances puis mon objectif c'était monté
tranquillement les échelons qui essayait
de pouvoir utiliser maman
voir pour pouvoir mettre des personnes
de diversité autre en place puis comme
pouvoir réutiliser justement le pouvoir
que j'ai à kerry monde en montant dans
la business mais un moment j'ai juste
réalisé que la façon que je montais dans
la business ce n'était pas en étant moi
même c'était juste en donnant qu'est ce
que les personnes vous laisse attendre
deux mois puis ça devient très difficile
si tu dois vivre constamment en voulant
être quelqu'un d'autre que toi même pour
satisfaire d'autres personnes c'est en
allant au déjeuner comme si je vais
là-bas depuis que je veux pas les
québécois sont capables de voir une
facette de la personnalité d'un noir
peut être l'autre peut être intelligent
qui peut être mieux équipés de fâcher
des fois qui peut avoir un grand étendue
d'une personnalité comme tout être
humain un être humain comme ça pourrait
faire un ça pourrait vraiment aider la
situation par la suite pour n'importe
qui d'autre qui je le souhaite de tout
mon coeur que le prochain camp et en
dehors des sabres étaient noircis ou non
mais en arrivant dangereux jésus
réconcilier ça avec mon côté compétitif
fait jeter comme tu sais quoi
genre après une semaine 2 j'ai réalisé
que j'étais je t'apprécie pas mal dans
les personnes et maison puis je savais
qu est ce qu il fallait quelque chose
pour me rendre en finale pour gagner
fait clasher comme jeux dessus le condo
jeux dessus être monsieur parfait où
monsieur moi même qui va permettre
l'évolution de la laque noire amour et
puis c'était un travail extrêmement
difficile que chaque soir je me
questionnais jeter comme my gun en ce
moment alors j'ai pas eu de la dune moon
toi même dans cette situation la
quitterai jamais accepter que quelqu'un
parle demain à métier en même temps il
faut manager nos relations si tu veux
trop loin c'est un moment que je dorme
accueille jusqu'au 6 c'est fou mais
c'est fou ce concept le pic toi tu vivre
ce petit tout le pense dans même team et
on est probablement le seul participant
qui avait son arrière de la tête mais si
j'étais un participant blanc jeudi
pourrait y va aussi de bien paraître
pour ma communauté et les personnes qui
se disent est ce même pas c'est même pas
une idée ce même pas dans le
c'est piqué quelques toi ça soit le cc
puis je l'avais fait pas j'en ai parlé
aux gars justement qu'ils nous faisaient
les confessions à chaque fois un moment
parce qu'il était quand même là qui a ri
entrevue d'une façon en audition puis
depuis le début la saison 6 est quant à
lui un confessionnal tu étais plus calme
tu penses à démont on voit que t'es jean
bouin qui est gentil très bien je lui
expliquer cette situation l'a quittée
foule compris en ces pays qui comme ok
ben t'as raison
puis je le comprends puis je tâche avec
ça mais après rendu le show c'est un peu
plus maintenant confessionnal situe ce
qui arrive peut me donner un show
pendant que sa fille qu à la fin comme
j'ai réalisé que c'est un peu plus comme
c'est pire pour moi aussi j mal pensé à
tout la situation je m'étais dit que si
j'étais pas moi même ça allait m'aider à
me rendre plus loin mais le fait que ce
n'est pas moi même ça m'a mis moins de
temps caméra ça a fait justement des
gens peu plus vraiment s'attacher à
notre relation parce que s'ils pensent -
puis alex anne candies pense
profondément
on n'a rien de négatif pendant saison il
y en a un autre couple qui avait un gars
comme une pétition contre lui il y avait
un autre gars qui à scarlett est un
footballeur pendant le show il disait si
zemmour et à maureillas de loin et puis
en train de regagner une main puis je
les adore mathieu mais c'est juste comme
la comment le show ont fait paraître les
trois candidats masculins mais je suis
souvent la personne qui avait le moins
de tâches à son arsenal on veut dire
mais c'est juste que je fais moi même je
comprends ce que tu dis le moins de le
moins de tant de moments à être montré à
la télé le moins le monde de voix sans
que ceux ci j'ai faut le public badauds
avec toi sur quelque chose parce qu'il
me rappelle c'est dans la maison au
début tout le monde te disais souvent
c'est vous avez l'artois fidji si vous
allez gagner pinoit intérieurement des
maisons c'est lui qui a ri alexandre il
tout le monde les aime ils font rien
négative pis ça va bien se passer
puis tout a eu un moment d'erreurs de la
part du show à joannie six mois c'est un
moment d'erreurs que chez une promesse à
karl que j'ai accès resort venus passent
la semaine d'après je l'éliminé puis
quand c'est éliminer les deux
les lions c'est voter l'un contre
l'autre excité comme ok ben négatif il
le monde s'en rappelle foule que j'aurai
à mes côtés de matières et sans ça c'est
ce que j'ai rationaliser peut-être que
tu puisses tu es rendu leur cheminement
mais tout ce que je me disais sic serait
pas été sûr j'ai raté quelque chose
d'autre serait pas été sûr parce que je
dirais qu'on le fait le show je te
demande si tu le dis c'est le show
johnny ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'on
ait fait un sketch de 15 minutes ou est
ce qu'on le citait toutes les
candidatures étaient quelque chose
d'autre se tient jeudi à serait pas été
chaud là ça aurait été quelque chose
d'autre qui aurait été pris hors
contexte qui arrêtait miller qui a été
la tâche c'est jeudi affecté une fois
que tu rationaliste eu la promesse non
pas la première c'est si ça prend
quelque chose ça prend un moteur
narratif puis on connaît assez l'équipe
de prod qui ont fixé leur job de faire
un show avec celui ci serait pas été ce
serait quelque chose d'aussi simple
tâche et son image mais dans un jeu
comme ça à être posée peut être réfléchi
c'est pas encourager c'est marrant je
sais pas les types de personnalité qui
fait ou à la télévision même si moi je
pense que dans la vie c'est comme c'est
emile et réfléchie déposé détruisent et
à raison plutôt que kate dans l'émotion
puis dans les villes sauf que dans un
jeu comme ça c'est parce qu'ils
recherchent les réseaux puissent
exporter le hors du commun flamboyante
qui prend de la place
c'est moi qui ai dit c'est pas moi c'est
ça dans le fond les gens vont
recommander pendant le show tout le
monde pékin qui a ri té le gars dans les
maisons qui est tout temps les longues
conversations philosophiques
psychologique avec tout le monde autour
de toi ils vont être coupés au montage
si moment d'une conversation trois
heures que tu ne passes avec quelqu'un
dehors pour penser à pourquoi peut-être
envers son père qui reculait depuis les
années
un fake c'est sûr que c'est sûr que
c'est des conversations comme ça tu sais
je sais comme 80 98 % des conversations
sont allées dans la maison c'est de
convertir encore 100 masseube et c'est
tellement rien autant dire que tout
commence à connaître les gens tellement
profondément que tu connaisse vraiment
un autre niveau mais métis c'est le 2 %
qui montre assez simple c'est ce qui
était parfait après pour moi en faisant
le podcast et que c'est même sur les
réseaux sociaux je peux être quelqu'un
qui veut faire genre d'épreuve
niaiseries tout le temps fait que je me
dis les personnes qui vont très attaché
à qu'est ce que vous faites pour la
suite de ma carrière c'est des personnes
qui vont avoir pris le temps de me
connaître c'est parce que si tu t'assois
qui coûta un podcast de 1h30 2h que
shaikh quelqu'un puis qu'après reconnais
que ma personnalité a su certains points
qui souhaitent comme ok ben je laime
pour cette raison là où je les aime pas
pour ces raisons là mais tu me connaître
pour vrai et c'est vrai reconnaît des
petits segments que tu es à la
télévision on pouvait voir de temps en
temps tu sais il ya peut-être moins de
monde qui vont écouter le picasso
complet mais non il faut l'écouter vont
avoir quitté le plus longtemps parce que
ça va resté avec eux mêmes plus
longtemps puis voir un sentiment de
proximité bien plus fort que toucher 500
mille personnes avec un secteur du
versus quelqu'un qui écoute ont pas de
carte complète j'écoutais ton podcast
complet keita driss par exemple seppi
c'est faux le bon tu apprends foule mais
j'en reviens à la question était gelé le
projet de juste parler de racisme
jean vient la question qui tue mais
cette pression là c'est comme la preuve
qui est tellement plus de représentation
des minorités dans le dans télévision
pendant le public qui était dit mettons
un blanc fait quelque chose des caves
télévision expression double ce on veut
saisir eux mêmes auront 8 cm jamais
convoi a plié sa généralité de sa
couleur de peau c mais qu'est ce qu'on
comprend pas d'occupation double ou du
québec en général c'est que pour ce
monde comme nous t on habite à montréal
montreal c'est vraiment un micro
représentation de du québec qui n'est
peut-être pas au réalisme à la
représentation
si toi tu grandis en région pickeu
u13 peut-être dans ton parcours scolaire
puis qu'après tu vois un noir à la
télévision au québec qui agissent d'une
certaine façon mais si consciemment ces
personnes-là reflète son opinion
peut-être général d'une communauté we do
top secret mais à la fin c'est moi je
peux comprendre comment quelqu'un on
arrive le même temps je l'exclus pas
nécessairement pas je me dis en 2020 est
tellement de matériel en ligne pour être
capable d'agrandir ta perspectives
générales un groupe qui s'y dit il qui
arrive tu penses que c'est la
représentation des noirs ou québec
ben mon dieu pauvre knott et ceux qui
pensent à moi je suis vraiment triste
pour cet égard l'homme en même temps on
a là en audi j'étais conscient que ça
n'aide pas à aller faire partie de mon
fardeau on va dire de de porter la
communauté surtout si je me rends de
loin
c'est une énorme c'est une énorme
différence grosse responsabilité et spi
s'est séparé à l'essai moi j'ai été
chanceux parce que j'ai grandi puis j'ai
vu c'est les deux côtés de l'équation
que j'ai vu mes parents qui arrivait du
cameroun puis que quand j'étais plus
jeune c'est plus pauvres grandit à
montréal nord puis mes parents sont
super et du qui est ma mère elle a un
billet mon pari entre doctorants
journalistes ces sections qui ont eu une
fois ici il faut arriver si tu es mon
paritaire
un show de radio cameroun quittait foule
populaire genre comme c'est déjà une
vedette du cameroun depuis un moment du
monde en france aucun n'ayant entendu
parler de lui puis ils ont proposé de
venir faire ses études en journalisme
justement au au québec
ok ouaip et c'est comme ça que j'ai eu
l'opportunité puis il ya emmené ma mère
avec lui puis ma mère est comme ça il
peut payer son cégep et après commencé à
monter les échelons l'université puis
elle a fini avec un b j'ai vu comment
mes parents sont venus de absolument
rien
ma mère vient d'une famille est 18e une
famille de 19 ans comme pauvreté pur
après moi c'était vrai chez le dernier
de la famille fx a commencé déjà à
augmenter si on était rendus dans un
quartier raisonnable de montréal or
c'est tout le monde tous tes frères sont
nés au québec
mon frère guinée au cameroun a manqué
justement pendant que mes parents
faisaient 6 et leurs études il fait
clairement pas d'argent qu'ils ont dû
laisser mon frère 5,7 au cameroun avec
la famine exactement plus étaient
clémentes off pour lui mais après quand
ils ont dû chatelus se placer ils ont
ramené mon frère et ma soeur mais du
monde s'appuie moi même
est ce que faisait beaucoup
d'allers-retours encore pour le voir
souvent non il n'y pas tant d'argent 19
ans au cameroun sans voir ses parents
s'étaient rallystique mans puis après ça
c'est à qui revient d'un mois exactement
tina déjà difficile pour juste super
difficile mais mon frère je peux si vous
êtes au courant mais mon frère
c'est en ce moment je pense qu'il 12e
troisième meilleur joueur de ce que la
marque pour l'équipe nationale soit
quelqu'un indienne el ali gerba piégé
pour l'impact pendant longtemps les
joues en europe itou puis il y avait une
rage une feinte sur le terrain tout le
monde pouvait pas expliquer pouvez pas
comprendre quand tu connais un
background solucom se succèdent comme un
oui ça fait 250 je pense c'est mehdi qui
racontait l'histoire du l'exercice
mentale d'imaginer un boxeur qui est
alain gal il naquit qui vient d'une
famille qui tu es bien nantis puis
l'autre ceux ci gagnent pas son combat
il n'y a pas de bosse à terme exactement
ce que c'est sûr que lui qui a deux rien
à perdre vos gagner il va peut-être pas
de gagner mais derrière c'est exactement
ça l'a également un match tu veux jamais
être capable de frustrés comme lui
intérieur mortes et toute la rage qui a
le taux relevé après un coup c'est
surtout ça c'est sûrement la résilience
puis même chose pour ton franc arty la
résilience de capable de direct 8 kw
associé il mais dont un coup dur qui
arrive dans ta vie tu dis ça c'est si
c'est possible et c'est quoi un coût
moins d'en face quand on a mangé pendant
des années et des années était dans le
pays pour orthez puis après c'est la
suite des choses mes parents ils ont
foulé du qu'ils ont foule comme sont
intelligents puis c'est de rentrer dans
des quartiers de montréal dans les
années 80 90 personnes acceptent qu'ils
achètent leur kipré laure baëté marie
d'epizon du bon emploi api pas cause de
leurs crédits c'est toi que sa fille aux
longs cours exactement puis finalement
il décide à la mort alors parce que la
communauté - l'ours comme 22% à 25% noir
fait que facile à accepter
qui pendant souvent je me rappelle je me
posais des questions c'est comme quand
on vous êtes bien et du ski vous êtes
baptisant pourquoi vous avez commencé
votre compagnie et si mes paroles d'une
compagnie qui a maintenant et du succès
qu'il connaît comme à nice
ces compagnies qui promouvoir les
opportunités d'afrique de la sphère en
afrique
inquiet pour compagnie north american
pie européen théâtre
mr wes puis chacun annuellement avant il
y avait un magazine vraiment qu'ils ne
sont pas régulières il y avait
maintenant c'est ils ont ils ont un
forum chaque année pas mal investisseurs
les gouvernements ils viennent au palais
des congrès après ajustement aux
questions qui peuvent aller investir
pour des opportunités en afrique mois
puis moi je trouve ça mal mais je me
disais c'est tellement risqué puis à mes
temps vous quand j'étais plus jeune vous
étiez plus pauvres puis on n'avait pas
encore déménagé dans un quartier plus
aisé
j'étais comme c'est quoi que vous et
motivés à partir cette compagnie le pire
si j'avais pas une réponse très costaud
un petit quine mais en grand sage c'est
juste comme aoki ils ont pas eu
d'opportunité quand ils étaient dans
leurs emplois respectifs
on le sait ne pas monter on laissait pas
avoir la place des personnes qui
devraient avoir dans la compagnie étant
différenciation évidemment leurs
qualités fait qu'un certain poids des
comme je peux travailler pour quelqu'un
puis avoir la moitié du dollar ou je
peux la voir le dollar complet en
faisant parfois exactement pour cent
plus de respect pour mes parents même si
j'en avais déjà énormément qui c'est
juste difficile de voir justement là le
contrat cd comme souviens d'un quartier
comme ça puis après tu arrives dans un
quartier comme maintenant que je suis à
fontainebleau à blainville
puis je comprends maintenant beaucoup de
choses des deux côtés ça me fait
réaliser inquiet si je veux avoir une
certaine place dans la société si je
être capable d'intégrer d'autres
personnes si je capable de m'intégrer
voici cette façon là qu'il faut que tu
agissent puis comment le monde vont
accepter puis c'est difficile parce que
souvent tout de dire ben je vais devoir
être moi même si comme il va falloir
changer en entrevue puis quand j'étais
plus jeune j'ai un accent un peu plus à
africains riverains plus à montréal air
me dire mais comme je me suis rendu
compte rapidement si jal entrevue pige
pas un exemple québécois tout d'un coup
ben jabr là dessus c'est comme ils
cherchent un noir mais cherchent un
endroit qui est le monde vont comprendre
et puis parce que les termes token
exactement puis moi j'étais juste comme
c'est un peu moi qui
me fait rire c'est que nous avons la job
je le fais c'est un peu la même chose
pour aller à rodez je savais que tu vas
les choses pour aller à rodez pour me
rendre au 10 mai un certain point chaque
nuit là j'étais dans mon livre je t'ai
quand c'est comme ça prend en fait j'ai
commencé à prendre chez pascal à la
pilule - exactement ils m'ont donné des
fois quand j'étais gamin qui s'est
produit
pas capable je sais pas qu'est ce que
j'ai pu un moment à force de réflexion
en force de méditation comme jeudi
celles comprises et après la fois très
intéressant je suis le genre on pourrait
partir sur toutes les cultures gm était
juste pour l'histoire et et par an men
on peut pas s'imaginer le sacrifice que
c'est des kits et à terre natale 10 août
vécu ce que tu connais
puis la tachetée en outre son
attachement ou est-ce qu'on a grandi
puis de laisser la tristesse la peine
qu'est que ça que ça que revenir ici
élever les enfants tout en étudiant les
commandes comment difficile que seppi
travail en provence qui subviennent à
des besoins qui te rends compte que tu
peux même pas avoir de jobs d'été
d'airbus que et qui te moins
d'opportunités que les autres et qui en
plus en bout de ligne d'une compagnie
qui redonne à ta communauté mais les
semaines j'en ai dit j'en ai des
frissons c'est maroc jeudi puis j'en ai
des frissons juin moi je suis super
humain dans ce sens que je comprenais
pas tout ça ne tire juste un petit à
petit adolescent en tabarnak quand les
choses à l'époque comme il le voulait
puis
des fois mais quand tes amis autour de
toi il fonda fort que toi tu peux pas
faire autrement que tu fais mais leur
tabarnak pourquoi pas moi exactement
et puis quand justement c'est ce qui
très difficile moi j'ai commencé je
n'avais pas le droit où je pouvais pas
faire certaines choses qui après mes
parents ont finalement russe avoir du
succès dans leurs compagnies que là je
pouvais mais ils ne laissaient pas
nécessairement parce que il voulait que
je comprenne la valeur de tout ce qu'ils
ont fait de la valeur de l'argent la
valeur du des sacrifices qu'ils ont
faits qui comme adolescent moi je suis
jusqu'à nobel à pourquoi je peux pas
j'ai pas avoir de l'argent pour aller
voir tenir mes amis étaient à lille est
il exactement milliers moche comme ben
non il va falloir que tu me prouve qu'à
l'école tu veux travailler force il va
falloir que tu sois sage faut que tu
arrêtes de dire des niaiseries en classe
comme je le faisais moi c'est pour ça
mes parents j'ai comme et jean
charbonneau orford comparativement à
d'autres à 5 janvier autour de moi qui
les ai pas mal de niaiseries puis ils
ont quand même instaurer une discipline
incroyable puis mon frère a été super
difficile avec moi en grandissant le
surtout dans le sport parce que moi
c'est une chose qui justement ça me
faisait foule de peine parce que mon
frère mais ton jeu franchement j'ai
commencé le basket bord puis il y avait
tant il venait me voir puis j'avais fait
le parti le riz à la soirée d'avant puis
le matin voyait pays était comme tout je
pense que trop loin en faisant tout je
pense que tu travailles fort et il me
disait tout temps les petits
commentaires comme ça puis de 1 mois je
vous voyais ça comme un petit air de
laissant égocentrique j'étais juste
comme acquis il jaloux parce que quand
j'étais j'ai quand il était jeune fille
avait pas toutes ces affaires le puits
s'il vous plaît me supporter tout en
train de dire des affaires négatif puis
je te prenais pas la conscience de juste
pensé comme je suis pas reconnaissant
pour tout ce que j'ai lu ça foule était
difficile justement comme vous éditez
tahri pendant sept autres parents puis
tu viens au québec qui a une certaine
peut-être frustration par rapport à ce
pic pour tarnos plus haut niveau au
sport professionnel possible c'est mon
frère et je suis content ronaldinho
compte mais si rennes en double c'est
fou pis je mets
un sont pas encore en grandissant je me
suis juste rendu compte de l'ingratitude
que j'avais ça vous change et plein de
façons que je voyais à la vie et puis
plein façon dont laquelle j'ai approché
toutes les situations qui je pense que
c'est pour ça que le débat en ce moment
pour moi y est un peu difficile avec
l'association du racisme parce que même
moi en tant que noire au québec j'ai eu
beaucoup de privilèges
puis j'ai beaucoup de désir de pouvoir
aider la communauté un certain point je
j'ai l'impression que c'est très
difficile pour la communauté justement
de voir m quelqu'un de mon site qui
était dans un show pig i qui parlait
comme un québécois on va dire qu'il ya
eu aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'il s'est
mis avec la belle blonde on lutte se met
avec naomi ou d'autres personnes comme
ça qu'il y avait dans le show de couleur
puis j'ai reçu plein de commentaires de
ce genre là c'est quoi ta peut supporter
les autres noirs qui était dense au
protocole voté pour réel puis à la
bassée sera la base moi je touche commun
est sécable si j'aime une fille j'arrive
à la fille que j'aime chine
je vais pas aller vers la fibre pour la
sympathique et ouais mais après la
seconde dans la ville que tu arrêtes de
juste voir les choses en surface et
essaie de comprendre pourquoi quelqu'un
virgin certaine façon mais c'est là je
me dis ok je vois comment tu ressens
voici comment je peux utiliser mon
expérience puis si justement de ta
propre
je pense que c'est là que le débat va
être plus un c'est quand les gens vont
arrêter d'essayer d'attaquer les gens
sur des situations qui vont commencer à
essayer de les éduquer par rapport à
qu'est ce qu'ils font puis en ce moment
je pense que c'est beaucoup des attaques
tout entier pourquoi t'as pas mis ton
corps et noir pourquoi tu fais ce que tu
fais ça mais c'est pas comme ça qu'on va
avoir un dialogue sainti bats moi j'suis
d'accord d'exxon ce que ce que ce que je
suis un désir de quelqu'un qui est écrit
mettant sur instagram telle affaire
par rapport à où est écrit peu importe
où le par rapport au fait je te manquent
pas tu sais pas marcher avec une
personne de couleur à odile ce que tu
viens juste de dire de prendre la peine
d'essayer avant tout choquée parce que
c'est facile de choquer
c'est les ego sur instagram ça monte
vite c'est facile de faire un leurre
pourquoi thierry de te sentir à taghit
sentir critiquer mais de prendre le
temps de comprendre d'où ça vient
c'est ultra un portage je donne un
exemple moi j'écrivais des décombres
pour enfants mais avant d'aller super
mandala puis j'avais écrit un texte qui
était sur un officier de police qui
était gros pic le cultivaient tous les
stéréotypes d'un gros policier fait qu
il était pas en forme mais t'as
programme court il court après les bains
la seule chose qui le motivait c'était
manger dans un gic g crise ' dans une
époque où sql la grossophobie ce de même
pas un mot que je connais c'est encore
un puits en sortant des deux ans autant
daudet mais je pense plus ça fait
longtemps que j'ai écrit dans mon coeur
est ici ça existe plus sur le pilat il
ya une fille qui m'écrit puis qui
m'écrit en juin 1900 mah ma fille
revenait de l'école puis dit j'ai vu ton
au dessus puis je trouve ça quand même
scandaleux que tu as écrit ce texte lu
puis le mois instinctivement je me senti
profondément attaqué parce qu'à dix et
puis elle avec ton aussi ça serait un
genre puis mon premier feeling c'est
comme des boss est hissé juste un texte
c'est comment on rit puis là après ce
après cette vague le 2 comme de me
sentir comme se j'essayais de comprendre
des sites phares
sinon cette soir là aux raisons pourquoi
est-ce que la fille prend la peine de
m'écrire puis un message respectueux dit
sûr que ce qui est écrit ce gros coeur
de remployer nano mais qu'ils apprennent
la peine mais j'ai reçu ce message de
exact luthuli ignorent complètement ce
que ledit plus pertinente mais carey
pris la peine de me dire que ça fait
tarnec ce puits que la lave et lui seul
avait trouvé ce avait trouvé que ça
faisait aucun sens puis étaient déçus
que j'avais écrit sortir puis une fois
que j'ai réfléchi je me suis dit si tu
quoi j'ai participé à entretenir un
stéréotype
la personne le site police aurait très
bien pu être mince puis avoir les mêmes
motivations aurait très bien pu être une
femme avons les mêmes motivations
il est très bien pu arrêter tout puisque
j'ai choisi de faire c'est entretenir un
stéréotype fais ce que tu dis tout
savoir sur tout support une cette année
là pour te dire que tu as raison quand
tu dis quand tu te fais dire quelque
chose par rapport qui vient d'une place
de moins grand privilège que la tienne
si je voudrais moi que c'est pas comme
si moi même j'avais vécu de la
grossophobie et antiques envers moi et
j'ai toujours été en forme tu t'es fait
quand ça vient d'une place - privé j que
la tienne c'est vraiment important et
c'est comprendre c'est que ce tabak
c'est tellement simple dans la vie alpha
puis je pense que c'est là que je peux
vous mentir dans la communauté on va
dire des influenceurs la seconde que
cette situation les deux joueuses de
recommencer je me suis fait prendre de
tout bord près de qom qui arrive qu est
ce que je devrais dire comment je vais
le dire qu'il doit à magog c'est comment
tu vis pièce que mon texte je suis en
train d'écrire là je me suis fait
envoyer un paquet temps il ya une
personne qui disait que j'ai envoyé mon
texte a qui arrivent comme en mai ce qui
arrive c'est juste livrés je suis
quelque chose de bizarre en soit si cela
puis qu'est ce que je disais au monde
sait que de 1
sans trop de pression parce que ça ça
doit venir du fond du coeur qui la chose
qui est drôle c'est que certaines
personnes de toutes les communautés at
on était vraiment rapide à attaquer tout
ce qu'ils ont pas parlé pendant cette
situation le un fake prenons une pause
meute on la comprend cette logique le
gentil tu vois une situation de façon
qui est complètement rageur spi qu'il
faut pas par pic c'est inacceptable qui
citant papa tu es quelqu'un qui est
égoïste qui est quelqu'un qui est racée
spitz contribuent au problème
je peux comprendre d'où tu vois cette
perspective là mais si tu es quelqu'un
de la communauté noire que moi qui ai dû
cependant toute sa vie constamment puis
que j'ai quand même dû me faire des amis
avec du monde autour de moi constamment
qui nie
réelle situation là est-ce que tout d'un
coup je me remette en question puis me
dire que toutes les personnes dans mon
environnement sont racistes à ce que le
feq t'as pas mis le corps est sûre ce
moment là pickton a pas parlé toute ta
vie quand situation-là arriver aussi
ça fait que témoin raciste parce que tu
as mis le corps et pendant le 0 0 01 %
de ta vie qui pendant les 99 points 9
99% ta vie tu fais encore alice et 20
n'ont fait que c'est pour ça qu'il faut
que tu prennes un step back
bon moi j'ai un exemple il faut aussi
j'ai un ami je peux dire son nom mais
qui est influence pi puis est de tous
bords tous côtés le monde est attaqué
c'est comme khiari pourquoi ton ami ex
pape puis moi je savais même avant que
le débat s'amorce que lui en janvier
d'italie chez italie chez sa blonde dans
qui devrait rencontrer ses beaux parents
puis noncesse avait rencontré sa belle
famille exactement puis son beau-père
son beau-père ait commencé à 10 heures
des affaires ibère à 6000 complètement d
accord avec ce qu'on veut mettre un b
plas dessus non mais c'était pas à cause
du bruit c'est que tu viens de nommer le
pitch métro abbesses accession le compte
du fait que c'est un rush sa belle
famille on sait clairement c'est qu'il
est bon il va aussi copé revient puis le
s'ils sont bons pas commencer à dire
plein d'affaires complètement racistes y
ont de lui demander de hockey ton ami
mon ami dirai plus de monde dix mois je
m'en vais c'est inacceptable
puis je sais pas comment toi tu es
capable blonde et x2 d'entre eux mêmes
c'était vraiment pas d'accord avec ça
puis l école bâtie je peux rien y faire
je peux pas changer huit et quand ben
moi qu'est-ce que je peux faire c'est
montrer je suis pas d'accord avec ça
puis mon allée avec moins une action
comme ça tu n'as que sont réellement
comme plus mort que de parler sur un
style exactement tpiy le fait qu'ils
aient promis un poste 15 l'insa g
l'internet dans les internets succès
pour le monde si si si c'est une
plateforme où ce que lui présentement
j'imagine y fait de l'argent qui
travaillent puis est ce que toi le fait
que ton boss que chypre du travail dans
une station d'essence
il ya promis un carré noir dans la vitre
de la station d'essence
ça veut dire que tout d'un coup reçu
lors stadium puis si tu comprends
certaines personnes c'est leur job des
influenceurs b qui est ce que moi je
suis d'accord avec le fait qu'ils
prononcent pas là-dessus référa blement
j'aimerais que tu dis ce qui est sûr
aussi mais un certain point
qui suis-je pour aller chercher le coeur
des gentils si ça vient ton coeur
sincèrement ben maintenant j'étais
capable de thé d'affaler step pour
pouvoir changer la situation
mais généralement je peux juste dire si
ce qui ne devrait pas ce qu'ils
devraient pas parce que si tu regardes
le vidéo de 8 minutes 46 secondes de
john floyd s'est pas assis pour que tu
sois outre et puis que tu souhaites de
toi puisque tu as besoin de plus pour
pouvoir faire pour pouvoir vouloir
commencer à thé du quillier sur le sujet
a piqué ben je sais plus quoi dire tu
sais c'est au 5e jeu direct et le co
président koré noir sécurité si tout
réfléchi la patente de dispense pas sûr
que le carré noir c'est la manière la
plus pertinente de contribuer
o la cause de la droite répit j'étais à
l'écart et noir en plus d'exemples
l'oeil et fera pas parce qu'il ya plein
de monde qu'ils ont mis le matin 13
heures plus tard douze ans plus tard ils
l'ont enlevé parce qu'il est historique
a expliqué pascal il ya eu un bâclage
des gentils quand vous faites si belle
et les vois qu'on devrait attendre
longtemps profac ya du monde qui l'ont
mis ils ont pointé les dos des autres et
vous le mettez pas faisait pas les
bonnes personnes qui l'ont enlevée sont
honnêtement c'est pas une bonne défaite
il faut il faut quand même réfléchir
peut être patient là-dedans type l'autre
l'autre truc aussi à ce que tu disais
que si je prends l'exemple d'une amie et
6 sensiblement la même situation que lui
en tiens je dire en termes de prix là je
le connais pas du tout mais j'imagine
compte qu une enfance qui se ressemblent
métier qu'est ce que je peux apporter à
la conversation
si la réponse est pas grand chose qui
est pas déjà été dit est ce que ça soit
vraiment quelque chose de prendre la
parole pour répéter quelque chose qui a
déjà été dit ou qui se fait répéter sans
cesse quelque chose qui te dit ça petit
répondu que c'était attendu par tout le
monde par exemple c'est l'autre à face à
la fois que j'avais que ça puis j'ai
deux volets comment je réponds à la
question en visite la première partie
c'est que si le carré noir le tue on va
aller dans les affres d'algorithmes
d'instagram que montrent les cas il faut
que tu l'enlèves pas ce qui en fait le
message hope et de passer à un âge de
personnes le message tout le monde vu le
monde tout le monde éducation du sol
celle ci parce que tu as vu un carré
noir tu veux être capable de t'informer
puis trouver l'information foule
pertinentes sur le sujet tandis que tom
gougaud littéralement pour aller trouver
toute information que tu as besoin ce
qui donne des excuses si quelqu'un
quitte et puissant après avoir bu
d'avoir des jobs floride pillards
d'avoir bu tout le monde qui très bonne
là dessus parce que c'est inévitable que
tu lui ferme les yeux petit chat est
dans le sort par le pot sur instagram
qui vont venir changer ta vie un certain
point parce que de secours dont se dire
oh ma gueule si loïc j'avais bercy c'est
au sixième gare et noir le un nom de
troïka
mais c'est l'addition de tous au fait
que ça fait vraiment puissant pas
exactement en pis la deuxième partie
c'est
la face c'est que la personne certains
points ne veut pas nécessairement
s'impliquer dans cette situation là où
dans cette cause là moi je vois pas
nécessairement ça comme un acte raciste
j'ai peut-être construire ce que j'ai
dit c'est peut-être pas raciste des fois
continuons le racisme même si je les dis
un certain point ci de cause le droit
des affaires peu après 30 ans est
activement raciste piette voix complice
par la science ça peut être complexe
s'appelle complices dans certaines
instances mais que j'allais dire c'est
que des fois il ya des personnes qui ont
5 lui tout là dedans je m'inclus là
dedans on est une race humaine l'être
humain à la base et ça aux fiches avec
si toi tu te dis je suis pas raciste je
veux je voudrais pas qu'une action comme
ça arrive à personne mais qui en ce
moment je préfère faire mon pose de
fille qui veut te mettre en maillot de
bain sur instagram
ben j'ai pas de voir comme une fille
racistes voire une fille qui la
situation
sa fiche puis malheureusement autres
d'avoir quelqu'un de noirs dans sa
communauté comme son futur ami ou
n'importe quoi qui ne cherchons com ça
va arriver
moi moi la marque beaucoup de mes amis
genre à parler subtilement défaut
secondaire des situations réalistes que
je vivais puis le moment que beaucoup de
mes amis ont commencé à comprends pas ce
que j'allais dans un secondaire quand
même vraiment en blanc c'est quand j'ai
commencé à conduire
mes parents ont eu du succès je
conduisais à 17 ans 18 ans déjà mercedes
puis je me suis fait arrêter avec mes
amis un moment trois fois dans la même
soirée
j'ai une amie en arrière ils commencent
à pleurer été comme boulot munchi pas
comment tu vis au moi je me frustrait
tout en tout treize pôles capitulation
zen même h et jusqu'à demain parce que
georges avec 15 ans puis mes parents me
disaient c'est juste comme c'est une
réalité puis un jardin points on la vit
il faut que je me trouve plus proche là
dedans parce que j'ai pas fait les
efforts auparavant c'est plus concret
d'essayer de changer la situation
quand je suis sorti des eaux d ouais
mais la face et que j'ai une certaine
personne moi même qui avait juste
qu'évoque je m'étais juste 10 c'est le
monde dans lequel on vit
bah c'est ça c'est ça je pense qu'ils
ranimé dans la situation présente s'est
toutes les espèces de passion
d'activisme dormant l'intérieur des gens
se sont comme réveillé puis de faire non
tél
on a redonné renaude revenons à une
goldwing allonger encore une fois
puisque je pense que si on le voit
beaucoup il ya beaucoup de aux états
unis et beaucoup d'activistes pro noir
qui qui avait arrêté de faire de
l'activisme puisqu'elle y font un sujet
barry fonds non ok on commence parce que
c'est comme le petit porsche dit que tu
dises j'avais des votes
j'avais accepté que c'était le monde
dans lequel on vit c'est triste c'est
triste mais c'est vraiment fort que
l'image de faire j'avais accepté python
là avec web store on le dit l'un comme
un fou tu t'es fait d'arrêter mais
jamais lu et je conduis la cadillac de
mes parents je propose que tu étais en
mars et des inquiétudes le mot je
conduis la cadillac des parents me
paraît depuis que j'ai mon âge il ne
faut pas arrêter le gypsy plus mais mais
que tu dis semaine ses 110 ans dit
beaucoup c'est révélateur de camp mais
j'avais accepté que moi ont contrôlé mes
amis j'allais me faire arrêter
souvent puisse allah est correct comme
ça parce qu'il ya deux côtés au racisme
que je vois comment les gens peuvent-ils
avec ça c'est soit tu es vraiment
frustré soit tu vois dans l'acceptation
de la situation puis je trouve que le
juste milieu est très difficile à
atteindre
parce que c'est trop d'émotions fortes
c'est quand quelqu'un de taille ou de
fait une situation juste parce que il ya
vu la pigmentation ta peau tu peux pas
réagir de façon vraiment compréhensible
habituellement ci soit tu dois genre
près de l'amour pitt comme mais c'est
comme ça que j'essaie de suri glaciation
du choix tu veux juste être en colère je
vois ce que je peux m'estimer de mener
ce combat là à chaque jour de combats
toutes injustices leur médecin et
vivable à malaunay même c'est trop c'est
trop dur et non c'est trop et puis c'est
pour ça que moi je pense que tu aimais
tant d'exemples de ton ami ou des
influences en général tels en ce moment
tout le monde s'était pas au courant
qu'il y avait ce genre d'injustice le
dans le monde dans la société maintenant
tu le sais
fake là la chose morale à faire la chose
on peut appeler ça une responsabilité de
commencer par informer sur les quais
c'est quoi puis c'est une tribune t'es
pas obligé me semble que la chose morale
à faire c'est contribuer à ce moment
tous et c'est la bonne chose à faire
c'est la baule
c'est ce que j'ai réalisé puis pendant
tout le temps je servais naudé subi deux
mois
j'avais pensé que le monde mais côté
potes je tire sauce avec x nombre de
favoris dans ma tête savez peut-être pas
un impact si la maison j'ai décidé de
parler de toutes ses instances lopy
qu'est ce qu'ils nient et je sais que je
trouve ces jeunes parce que c'est ce qui
découle longtemps facebook je me mettais
tout temps des textes de situations qui
thème qui m'est arrivé peut monter com -
club de real id porter plainte de
retrouver dans votre cas décrivait des
textes de longs textes de remettre aux
situations de racisme qui m'est arrivé
puis le monde me connaît sur tout comme
ben c'est logique que maintenant qu'il
ya eu une plateforme qui vont parler de
façon plus prononcée puis puis 6,6 pour
ceux qui aiment et on m'en lasse puisque
les faits la manifestation s'est passé
il y en a plein qui était surpris mais
moi c'est juste comme naturel que
j'allais en parler parce que c'est le
sujet c'est un nouveau combat pour toi
pour un nouveau combat c'est juste que
je n'avais pas réalisé que non en fait
je n'aurais pas réalisé si j'ai juste
compris maintenant que la situation me
donne comme un stage le monde vous
m'écoutez en ce moment par rapport à ce
qu'ils utilisent la en crise de bon
escient parce que c'est si on peut faire
un changement puisque je sens ce moment
avec le monde veulent se changer mais si
je peux t'aider justement à avoir cette
empathie envers notre communauté peut
dire que qui je bloque mon enfant lui
dans un monde qui du monde peuvent se
faire tuer par la couleur de leur peau
pour la couleur de leur peau
mais voilà comment gérer la situation
c'est un peu le contexte on veut dire
est que le tout le contexte
environnemental en ce moment où c'est
les travailleurs pauvres tout ça c'est
des causes qu'en ce moment il ya
beaucoup d'activistes mais beaucoup de
personnes qui ont les mêmes idéologies
mais qui font pas des actions concrètes
en ce moment parce qu'ils ont qu'eva
sont juste dit
je dis moi avec jean mon compost à
changer la planète c'est la face et que
si tout le monde s'est dit ça ya
personne qui agit
puis moi j'en faisais partie ce problème
et je me suis dit ben je suis est qui
moi pour dire aux gens et mais les noirs
puis maintenant je réalise que ok sinon
vous m'écoutez ben je sais pas le du
mieux de mes capacités mais en même
temps je suis une voix et un million
d'autres à écouter puis si je peux te
référer à d'autres personnes plusieurs
comptes plus intelligente plus informés
ben je le faire puis toi entre le moment
où s'est faite aux dés puis récemment
avec les récents événements tu avais
subi un petit peu notre côté justement
pour pas trop déranger seppi moi ma
mentalité avec la situation c'était que
le monde au québec ne sont pas racistes
ils ont peur de nécessairement mais sont
juste comme un peu indifférent qui sont
peu sont pas attachés à les gens de
notre communauté parce qu' on connaît
juste pas généralement c'est que moi je
m'étais dit comment je vais être capable
de rassembler les deux mondes c'était en
utilisant la plate forme pour être en
contact avec des personnes qui sont plus
reconnus comme étant dans mon podcast
au début j'avais une liste d'invités
vrai en plus c'est fou le populaire pour
une personne vraiment influenceurs des
artistes et des gens de milieux plus
blanc je me dis pour que les gens
écoutent ma conversation avec un noir va
falloir qu au début il soit et dans
notre conversation avec un blanc un
puits le ca a juste accéléré processus
qui est maintenant le monde sont créés
au québec on veut qu'on veut c'est du
kif et qu'on va lui coûter un peu plus
maintenant mais généralement moins c'est
ce que je voulais faire je les justes
m comme le mettre en valeur avec des
personnes qui vont pouvoir aider la
situation puis par la suite j'ai deux
capables de mettre de l'avant
toutes les belles choses devant la
communauté puis c'est cette stratégie
match superbe stratégie dans tout ce que
je suis zen blanche au pis si je pense
que il ya des meilleures stratégies clos
puis je sais pas si c'est là que je
voulais faire au départ c'était la bonne
si j'aurais juste continu du contenu est
avec mes convictions
on verra le temps de le dire mais c'est
c'est la chose que je dois y étaient à
long terme je voyais que si
les gens un certain point son calme ok
qui arrive le trouve neige le trou vote
tout ce qui va faire je l'écouté quand
j'ai avoir une conversation avec
quelqu'un qui en axant foule prononcé
créole qui foulent dans le black out la
culture générale blacks puis que tu va
réaliser que malgré son accent malgré
ces expressions qui sont différentes à
la tienne ni quand même fort intelligent
foule puis c'est là que ça va être ça
c'est notre culture justement que cette
culture le conte n'a pas accès on n'est
pas encore rendu je pense d'abord d un
participant aux débats aux des exemples
mais qui est vraiment comment dire qui
vient d'immigrés outil qu'est vraiment
il ya un plus grand clash culturel
moi c'est ça la fin qui est drôle c'est
que j'ai grandi à montréal or j'ai des
amis dans le basket ball dans la musique
toutes ces affaires là sa mort rendue
tellement proche de sa puis je suis
capable de vivre dans cet environnement
le mais après chalet dans un secondaire
jean tigana de switcher d'un accès
directement je peux le faire n'importe
quel accent puis ça c'est une de mes
forces je pense que justement en
revanche rejeté un conseiller financier
puis c'est dans le milieu des affaires
des vendeurs tout le temps puis c'est
juste que je suis capable de m'adapter
au mont autour de moi mais ceux-ci 1 ce
qui est ce que moi j'ai personnellement
les personnes leur succès ne devrait pas
dépendre
c'est ce que ça me rend pas plus
intelligent parce que tout d'un coup
plus un accent québécois comme si tu
écoutes le poker avec fabrice y en a
plein qui sont comme en chine quand tu
parles avec fabrice son accent est un
peu changé de site de plus une action
internationale puisse ou puis cochez
avec des amis vraiment plus un accent
plus haïtien je m'adapte aussi comme ce
qu'il veut en espagne si si tu parle
avec un accent québécois espagnol de
grenade en cas de demande
tu peux être compris mais si tu vois ce
genre de la personnalité tout en bas âge
dans l'accent de la place bellucci a pas
vraiment plus de connecter avec des
gentils un full important puis comme se
disent pas tout le monde qu'elle elle
que le luxe la possibilité ou l'ailé qui
capable de le faire
seppi puis justement celle ci un peu le
sujet du documentaire
brésil cannes dont on a tant parlé avec
fabrice et de toutes ces petites
micro-ajustement alors que vous mais
qu'elle vous quelques teams étendue aux
affaires on se rend même pas compte que
ça existe c'est justement le pilote d'un
petit peu de foi tamisez sa propre
culture pour profiter dans le da dans le
mode multi encore une fois pour qu'un
bon vivre à 100 il faut qu'un certain
une certaine sorte de de partage
d'intégration mais ça devrait pas être à
vous de faire la guerre aux métaux ou
aux minorités de faire 100 % du chemin
puis nous aux deux fois 0 % du chemin
c'est bien plus facile demain c'est ce
qui est drôle notre génération où c'est
l'être humain en général on sait qu'on a
une appréciation pour la facilité c'est
tout ce qui va être plus simple
puisqu'il va être moins demandant et
c'est quelque chose qui va attirer
beaucoup de personnes puis j'ai pas de
problème avec ça parce que je le
comprends tout en mettant comme moi je
me réveille pour m'entraîner à 5 heures
du matin puis généraux journée puis
toutes ces affaires le je sais à quel
point c'est un peu plus nice la journée
si j'aurai décidé de dormir jusqu'à
demain midi illustrer un qualifié puis
l'homme pas décidé d'être travaillant
mais se trouve qu'il faut pas que tu
juges nécessairement la personne qui
décide justement de faire moins
d'efforts la face qu'il faut que tu es
capable de communiquer qu'est ce que ces
efforts là ça va lui apporter technicien
breton
j'ai tout à apprendre des exemples soit
retirée si tu fais comprendre un enfant
que son éthique de travail et non son
talent c'est ce que veut le ramener dans
la nba où tout et n'importe quel
l'ex-sportif de haut niveau mais
intérieure mort cet enfant là va
peut-être avoir un désir de vouloir
travailler plus fort t'excite arrive à
faire comprendre aux gens qu'est ce que
leur acceptation vers d'autres
communautés
à long terme ça va leur apporter mais ça
va être naturel que les gens voudront
peut être assez spacieux 30 contes
module le monde accepte ans pour une
autre puis m'a permis de développer des
connaissances que j'avais pas dans un
bouillon sujet puis ça m'a facilité mon
approche conversation de conversations
avec des personnes de
ma communauté passe juste capable de
m'adapter d'entraidé situation puis
juste la diversité généralement je
trouve que c'est tellement un skieuse
qui important puis incroyable tu veux
pas juger ça comme un exemple en plus
mon paquet avec dominique
imagine tu avais une société où ce que
tout le monde te ressemble elle commença
serait pas qu'une plate puis la savoir
qu'est ce qu'il sait que c'est pour la
plupart du monde sait que là les
différencie âme et on sait dans une
communauté plus blanches qui capable de
les boire mais souffre qui était quand
même un confort parce que les personnes
trans sommes un petit peu mais le fait
que toutes ces personnes ne te
ressemblerait exactement se met très mal
à l'aise du fait que pourquoi le fake it
récent portant que ça te met mal à
l'aise aussi c'est pourquoi ne t'accepte
pas justement toutes ses différences et
puis se rend compte à quel point ça va
apporter en tant qu'être humain c'est
drôle parce que tellement de monde là
dedans qui vont voyager conte à la
rencontre d'autres cultures mais cannes
c'est chez nous on n'en veut pas aux
eaux d eau d en afrique du sud il y
avait beaucoup cette idée là aussi on
devrait cet esprit-là d'inclure la
diversité de de montrer surtout par le
fait que c'est en afrique de montres et
et la culture africaine puis le racisme
en afrique du sud le racisme en afrique
du sud exergue est ce que tu es ce que
tu toi d'un oeil externe est ce que tu
penses elle a bien été fait ou ça
l'était fait un peu pour cocher des
tchèques mois que tito que des documents
pour que chez une jarre ii a nommé lundi
at on fait notre part au site c'est
parce que moi mettons et je dois avouer
que j'ai depuis que je les fais jamais
suivi avec 100% d'éducation une saison
d'occupation double puis pour regarder
un épisode je les ai regardés dans les
maisons pitié mais d'un point de vue
extérieur on dirait qu'il y avait un
petit peu cette idée là de deux cachets
d box puis je sais pas comment
doublement et plusieurs points voici
comment on peut partir sur ce que tu
veux plusieurs 2 1 pour me prendre en
exemple je suis complètement conscient
que j'ai uniquement fait route
et parce que je sais moi donc je sais
que j'aurai exactement la même
personnalité en tant que blanc j'aurais
pas fait aux dépenses
je suis convaincu qu'ils c'est qu'est ce
qui te fait dire ceux ci le fait que
pour quelqu'un qui me ressemble sa
recherche
un modèle que ils n'ont pas généralement
fait que ça arrive à dire une sorte de
toxines pour qu'est ce que le show
télévision on parce que votre com qui
arrive est capable de bien fêter à
travers tout ça mais c'est un beau
bonhomme pareil en a plein je sais pas
personnellement je pense pas que j'ai
une caractéristique de ma personnalité
qui s'y voir le moi je rencontre tous
les jours des gens j'aime ça aurait du
monde puis moi je suis émerveillé chaque
fois je rends compte du monde à quel
point c'est le ils sont spéciales leur
façon puis cet aspect là ça a fait que
je comprends c'est quoi leur point je
comprends qu'il veuille ou pas on a
besoin de cette diversité là parce que
le fait que quelqu'un est plus à l'aise
maintenant cette année avec un quillard
l'enfant va faire que les années d'après
un syrie jean jérémy come to toute
l'étendue des noirs possible le monde
d'une étape à la fois ils vont être plus
à l'aise
comment ils ont montré l'afrique gd des
utilisations là dessus parce que
personnellement ils ont montré un aspect
magnifique de l'afrique puis mes parents
travaillaient là dans ses travers et
c'est trop mou voir les opportunités
d'affaires en afrique puis je suis
revenue puis il était émotif passé comme
toutes les années de travail qu'on a
fait pour que les gens s'intéressent à
l'afrique n'ont jamais autant été plus
aussi eu d'impact etc ans de prison
exactement pied à la basse et leur fils
qui va oser ils sont quand même là d'un
câble scotch faire mieux qu elles sont
venus ils étaient comme michael qu'on
savait pas à quel point les gens
s'intéressent à l'afrique maintenant
publie ses livres vol en afrique en ce
moment ils sont où il était donc obésité
troubles du québec du québec c'est ça ça
vous change et la séparait ce qu'ils ont
vu beaucoup dans leur business qui ont
vu des hawaiiens il rentrait du monde
puis avant il fallait pas dire que l'on
fait ça au 10 mai après si tu es fier
des théorèmes ont fait ce qu'ils étaient
limpide l'émission québécoise et puis
j'aime ses côtés le positif c'est faux
le positif le problème c'est que
j'aurais aimé que le show peut-être et
c'est plus d'aider aussi la communauté
fait veux pas moi les meilleurs moments
que j'ai vécus c'était après show qu'on
était avec juste une nounou avant la
finale qu'ils ont à nous contacter ou le
voyage à l'île maurice fait impression
d'être venu en afrique sud pourrait
passer l'humoriste va mettre aux
vacances de merde
puis une fois la bombe n'a commencé à
faire des activités plus dans la
communauté on ne gère qu'une chorale est
inspirante de trois semaines on
rencontre est vraiment du monde puis
c'est là que j'ai pu m'imprégner de
vraiment ma culture un peu africaine
puis rencontrer du monde puisse proche
de moi puis j'aurais aimé qu'ils ont
justement ceux capables de voir cette
différence puis être capable d'être
comme et c'est ce monde sont à croire
pareil malgré leurs différences parce
que je trouve que beaucoup des activités
ou des choses qui ont été faites dans
l'émission c'était dans du luxe tu es
dans genre quelque chose que le monde
sont à l'aise de faire généralement mais
si tu montes admettons communautés elles
toutes les personnes de la production
sont pas mal d'accord avec le fait que
la chorale compte aller le match d'hier
je pense que mon ami je pense quelque
chose qu'il est vraiment a touché sur un
moment incroyable on est à 10 montrent
en train de danser chanter avec eux
après nous donne à manger c'est des
pattes de poulet gens vraiment quelque
chose de wiki t'enlève les hommes
étaient sous le feu des brebis
après ces moments là tu es jusqu'à mon
dieu j'aime j'ai la foi la race humaine
parce que ces personnes là ils ont rien
puis arrive à être heureux comme ça
qu'ils sont capables de m'accepter
malgré genre mon privilège il me vois
pas comme un danger me vois pas comme de
façon négative il ne m'a compris ceni me
wade comme qui sont juste content
justement qu'on ait pris du temps pour
avoir avec heurté jarry mais c'est que
ce côté là soyez plus mis l'emphase en
même temps chez qui on a cherché que
c'est une business puisse comprendre
mais
m tu as les agences bord de l'étang
d'abord fait que c'est qu'on aimerait
c'est comme les boules quand vous avez
couché dans une zac ça l'est du kenya
puis ce que tu dis là un autre si on
était en voyage fait qu'on était off cam
qui on avait trois heures de show à
faire de l'aéroport jusqu'à la place
qu'on était sous l'eau il est arrêté à
amener puis il y avait des on est à la
zone village même fin fond de zanzibar
ou est ce que la terre rouge pilotes ont
concours elle appuie un des enfants qui
courent et les autres qui nous saluent
et qu'ils étaient contents être lopy
tout le monde faisait ne faisait des
saluts meetic tes impressions en italie
t on passe le long trip menti comme
c'est moi c'est mon premier contact avec
l'afrique c'est ce cd les enfants qui
sont contents de me voir bio rien tout
éclater dans une route de terre herman
piste et c'était débile gras pressé on
s'en va dans une maison sous l'eau qui
vaut 2000 pièces la nuitée place et si
le rêve à fontiers minutes on était là
puis on se disait l'abord on était plus
épanouie c'est qu'ici dans celui du club
moi j'ai l'impression qu'ils auraient
peut-être que c'est pas le même show
c'est peut-être que je pas en train de
parler d'occupation deux peut-être
suis-je en train de parler d'un autre
concept mais j'ai l'impression qu'il y
aurait une nouvelle quelque chose ce
n'était presque pas même chose tous et
des activités comme tu vas tu vas en
islande pour pouvoir les landes et de la
culture mais pour monter au glacier le
plus le plus aux artistes pour ea com je
pense que c'est ça mais mais mais je
comprends ce que tu dis parce que les
bourdes qui est doigt ce qu'était
vraiment ma culture c'est comme ça que
tu auras envie que le monde voie mais
c'est parce que le monde voit c'est le
monde voit doimo la chicane
il voit aussi le luxe mais c'est comme
s'est pas tu le si tu le sais c'est quoi
qui montera d'élite qu'est ce que tu as
fait réellement ces deux affaires
différentes
et puis ces maladies moi c'est une des
raisons justement prochain la finance
c'est parce qu'on dirait que je voulais
juste comprendre le monde dans lequel on
vit parce que c'est tellement important
elle est respectable thalys puis ça te
fait pas excusé mais justifié beaucoup
de choses qui arrivent jamais été un
problème avec la production comme angers
paru jamais été un problème avec des
décisions qui sont pris parce que tu
comprenais ce qu'on valide et je
comprends le bar bar moi c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on attend afin de situations lopy
c'est comme ça qu'ils c'est difficile un
peu de critiquer la société
mais s'il le faut paraît pas ce que tu
veux dire des gens d'agir d'une certaine
façon mais ça va leur faire perdre de
l'argent
puis tout le monde veut voir l'argent à
certains points mais c'est comme si
quand on fait pas assez ça c'est une
autre question c'est juste des débats
étant avec le capitaliste que je peux
juste des fois au cours des mois qui
serait juste folle je devais rebouteux
j'avais vu dans une news qui jusqu'à - à
l'est de la cité volontaires exactement
puis un autre côté que juste comme non
mais je comprends les motivations
derrière cette c'est le luxe et la
beauté comme la maison là on appris de
ce qu'on a vécu après caen ont été
finalistes
mon dieu que j'aurais habiter leur toute
ma vie puis que je me suis mis
confortable assez rapidement la bop it
it agissent puis en même temps si tu
peux comprendre pourquoi quelqu'un
voudrait habiter la fête c'est juste je
pense que quand tu comprends les deux
hémisphères c'est le petit capable
d'avoir un dialogue pour essayer
d'arriver à un compromis
puis si c'est que j'espère est justement
que la société que c'est qu'on soit
capable justement de tout temps essayé
de dialoguer pour avoir des compromis
plus sensée mais c'est tellement
difficile c'est comment je veux dire à
od de montrer des moments dans un petit
village avec des petits-enfants qui je
pense que somme toute limité il faut
quand même faire un show vraiment juste
des
de pagnes âge qui m'aimera baliste un
peu moins sur la base du show ti la base
du show le fondement du chose c'est
comme un plus
après ce qui rajoute un petit peu de
temps en temps le musée de l'apartheid
oublie-t-il d'affaires comme ceux ci
c'est du bonus serait pas obligé de le
faire ce qui pourrait le faire plus que
ce serait bon qu'ils fassent plus
sûrement est moins bien alex pour pas de
coupe et on est allé à mener dans notre
premier voyage en italie dans une église
en haut d'une montagne on a fait de
l'escaladé en ethiopie ces genres l'une
des églises les plus vielles sa date des
années 500 le sait et fauqué l'habitude
voix et des dessins sur les murs puis
ces genres d desprez qui jésus puis
plein façon mais qu'ils étaient comme
anouar de couleurs de produits ce qui
fait que ça te fait poser des questions
je sais quoi d'imagerie qu'on a vu dans
ces années là parce que leurs
communautés catholiques on ait subi une
des plus vieilles au monde pour plein de
questionnements pis on aborder ces
sujets là pendant qu'on était dans notre
voyage puis pour moi c'est un voyage
comme vraiment comme j'ai eu un éveil là
dessus puis après j'écoute le chaud puis
ses portes et huska mettons cartes
pauline etc puis s'écartent dit pauline
up il embrasse pic après sion sous peu
apprécié panis et d'embrasser au fait
dire qu'il ya plein de remporter là
qu'est venu embrasser deux filles dans
la même soirée
pis ils ont montré au total je pense en
cinq minutes de notre voyage
je comprends aussi parce que le show
était un grand soir et la sportivité
malade mais comme je pense qu'on aurait
pu amener la société généralement à
aller dans une direction vraiment plus
qu'un réfléchit plus intellectuelle pi c
j'espère du fond de mon coeur que
peut-être quelque chose comme ça d'être
montrée mais je comprends la baisse la
barre parce que c'est des shows fidèles
et documentaires puis de xian de voyage
jusque on voit les cultures où est-ce
qu'on vous tous ça existe des jeux puis
à pau 2 pour 1 5 million d'euros dont
ils utilisent les
justement toutes les deux joué à maupilé
premier degré daudet passer la poule a
man loves pour glisser une petite
affaire si je sais c'est juste si nous
autres on s'adresse à un public large
mais on essaie de traiter des sujets
plus important c'est le travail on se
brûle t on n'est pas je comprends qu'on
va absolument ce que tu dis ça me fait
rire c'est que je suis là parce que à
bali mais j'avais raconté sur le à bali
hong hong et en chine puis sandri qu il
part en voyage avec joanie à lille de
gesvres qui était juste un petit peu de
bateaux l'auteur le connais bien je dois
dire plus ouais bon de commencer et on
s'emmerde fait qu'il s'en va les deux
gerbes puis à caen qui reviennent de
cendres et qui est des colis
il nous raconte même pas à cause à cause
de rejoigne sa relation ils nous
racontent qu'ils étaient elles sont
allées monter un volcan pour aller
chercher quelque chose en haut puis
qu'il y avait des des denaisiens je sais
pas si commun qu'ils appellent les gens
de l'île de java 2 mais qui étaient là
qui qui faisait des allers-retours à
journée longue pour remonter du genre de
charbon par le mettre sur le dos puis
redescend décembre puis dit les gars et
on leur genou complètement défoncée dit
on des problèmes de poumons la plupart
mort avant 30 ans puis 10 et l appui
fait de sa journée longue
puis il distend drake il dit je suis
monté en rouge mais je mets à pleurer
patine nous raconte son histoire le
genre sale est transcendé le transpercer
d'un bord et de l'autre qui est
chambouler complètement lenzo dont
l'icône rock mais ce voyage le centre
était débile tiges de bolidage d'ivoire
sort de l'émission on écoute le showman
pi0ggia 0 point mort
ce segment là où peut-être qu'on voit
des gens montent et du charbon je sais
pas quoi le mais rien de rien remarqué
puis ses cendres et qui par la joie ni
de fils puis les couper avec fils qui
dit qu'un malware
vraiment ça y est mais elle effectua ni
sandrine goethe à côté lui quand combien
coûtent les émissions parce qu'on était
dans même chalet peut on écouter les
émissions tout le monde ensemble sans
abri qui écoutent ce les vois comment
son voyage il dépend quand le segment
termini cela est fait
tabarnak sans voix en bonne on a récusé
mission le port une fin de la journée
verte image et de médicaments jean lui
ça l'avait changé même plus voit sa tv
c'est comme tarmac qui après c'est
l'histoire d'un os et pony tail bien
pâle dans le dos dit elle
ça te paraît tellement merci rien
maîtres paraît tellement futile mais est
comparée de ces expériences le petit vie
moi j'ai tellement eu de la difficulté
avec sa pige jamais assez remercier
alexane avec se passe correctement et
dès que j'ai vraiment vécu des moments
incroyables en tant qu'humain à rodez
j'en parle avec les gens piste le plus
important de mon aventure sais comment
j'ai évolué comme personne à bonn puis
en même temps tilly moment convivial il
était tellement incroyable ont rencontré
tellement du monde des fois qu'ils ont
envoyé la pauvreté on voit le contrat de
cette société de l'afrique du sud qui
est le plus gros au monde il peut avoir
des gens qui sont millionnaires monde
qui habite dans dans un bidonville puis
si c'est des moments comme ça que je
connecte avec les gens vraiment pis j'ai
littéralement eu aucun drame n'étaient
même pas faire avec car c'est lui qui en
parlaient jamais su vraiment cette
situation là que l'ua m il y avait des
doutes envers juifs mais j'ai jamais été
fait refaire partir de là je t'ai jamais
agréable at il une fois j'ai haussé le
ton contre kiev n parce que le genre il
tenterait de crier des insultes et mon
ami piste -comme pas d'accord avec s qui
disait avec un moment j'ai défendu mon
ami mais après ça j'ai jamais dans aucun
drame de toute la saison
puis c est après c'est difficile de
juste voir que comme bella je n'ai pas
gagné parce que je suis pas un training
pour qu'est ce que le show voudrais tu
sais je suis pas au top pour c'est pas
vrai qu'une compétitif aussi d'avoir
cette réalisation la moitié
pas perdu beaucoup dans ma vie c'est
sympa même si mettons toutes les cartes
en main
céline avec avec une floch mais l'autre
comme une suite royale et qu'il paye sa
dernière carte c'est sage et très
volatil et comme j'ai joué
stratégiquement parfaitement puis comme
ça c'est un quart de la fin parce qu'il
ya un 25 cents des côtes libyennes
empêchent ce soir était quelque chose de
sacré mais passer deux tuiles mais si
sur le moment c'est que c'était un chien
pour déjà compétitive c'est chiant
perdre s'arrêter n'importe quoi j'aurais
perdu n'importe quoi et j'en ai bien sûr
une fille troisième les deux l'appui
confirmation il ya un moment qu'ils ont
compris qu'ils sont contents parce qu'on
avait laquelle on troque acquis mais si
on était en cours arrière pourront se
lancèrent la balle de baseball pee on
parlait foot est comme et le monde nous
avons une maison à ce moment ci ont fait
fort pour le reste la saison c'est jean
mi saison guillaume comme si on fait
faux col on sera en finale 1
puis on était comme on fait une focale
ou recommencent agence allait en 5
secondes on commence à écrire les gens
là dessus c'est simple on sentait la
balle c'est la marque on a joué juste
comme parfait dans les maisons si
jusqu'à près à la fin qu'on réalise que
tizi c'est un vote du public
ces situations le comme c'est impossible
à gagner
legault et joseph facal chatham en
affinant exactement mais si je devais en
bout de ligne c'est la perception du
public puis c'est plutôt le contrôle
plus rien ce contrat qui était pas le
contrôle sur commande a été démontrée te
contrôler ce que tu fais mais après ce
qu est-ce qui décide de montrer par
exemple comment le public le reçoive
comme en choeur site apprécié ou non
question de la donne par exemple c'est
que tout le monde vit pleinement qui
m'ont dit en tant que compétitivité
dessus en crise
de pas gagné la réponse est oui sauf que
qu'est ce qui est beau c'est que les
finalistes ont été tellement sens
pendant longtemps que la première chose
qui est venu en ami venu en tête ces
deux comptes en tabarnak mitchum
viennent de gagner d'or l'équivalent de
500 mille pièces piché jusqu'à 8
justement proches accueilli magpies
j'étais jusqu'à moi je suis tellement
content pour vous d'après le fait que
j'ai perdu sa gamme jeunes considèrent
plus tard mais si je suis sur le membre
d comptant pour ces personnes-là puis
c'est au bout du compte j'ai tellement
vécu que cette affaire-là savait juste
et est à ce titre i sur le sol mais
comme je suis d'accord chanter avec ce
puis je pense pas qu'il ya un moyen que
j'aurais pu mieux jouer la game puis
côté mais ne s'est pas de regrets mais
c'est en france qu'il faut que je sois
toi même
oui le pied côté je sais pas moi je me
dis que un certain point peut-être je
vais faire une autre boucle serait bon
finalement champions et d'erreurs avec
ce puits j'ai hâte de voir par exemple
la suite des choses c'est parce que nos
carrières respectives on va dans des
directions enfin on travaille fort puis
on essaie de faire que les cartes se
place pour nous mais on n'a aucun
contrôle rendu le sait ce qu'est ce que
tu veux faire qu'est-ce que tu envisages
qu'est ce qui serait un pacte pour toi
de personnellement j'ai une famille
quand même d'entrepreneurs chez peu
importe qu est ce que je veux faire ça
veut tout de mon contrôle du temps voire
le lit par rapport à des projets que je
veux faire présentement le fait que
justement j'ai commencé mon podcast
c'est que vous devez imaginer et un
plein de persécution comme ok je
voudrais tourner dans son studio je
répare safex assis une avenue que je
pourrai penser mais je me dis un certain
point je préfère prendre beaucoup de
temps
puis profiter de la situation dans ce
moment que j'évite contre up tout
l'aspect influenceurs pour voir
exactement que je veux faire pour la
suite des choses je pense que j'aurais
jamais l'opportunité autant dans ma
ville juste sept bacs et puis avoir des
réflexions puisse vraiment inquiet ce
n'est sûr on met de côté tout l'aspect
capitaliste de ckoi je veux faire de ma
vie pour gagner d'argent en ce moment ça
vient parce qu'elle fait des postérieurs
historique signé elle-même mais sauf que
pendant ce moment là je peux donner une
réponse qui trop précise juste
comprendre vraiment qui je suis
puis qu'est ce que je veux littéralement
puis comme je pourrais vous donner
réponse dans quelques années quelques
noirs ou lowe's mais je pense que je
vois cette révélation incertain ça vous
relance dessinée métier je pense
qu'aussi pts et entraîne déjà de prendre
un chemin par les prises de parole que
tu fais par les textes écrits par ton
podcast suzuki contribué quelque chose
c'est une session cinor métier seppi je
pense que c'est ce naturellement tu le
fais pas il faut continuer dans cette
direction de l'impression je pense que
tu es mon talent que je dirais qu'ils
hors de tous deux piges et autant au
monde commencé par voir si quoi vraiment
leur talent puisque autres les passionne
sa tour des communications fixes aller
dans n'importe quelle direction on
saisit au début c'était comme au québec
terme aux crimes de 14 un bon
communicateur l'entraînement fargy pense
que ce mardi après home vieux qui
baptisera alors ok puis après on sait
qu'en attique voiture et faire la télé
puis après c'est quand même hayatou
temps plein d'avenue c'est maintenant il
ya du monde disait bien parlé pendant la
situation du real en politique
dommage comme un le politique on sait
que j'ai trouvé un respect pour ces gens
là pour me dire qu'ils vont prendre le
gars de rodez c'est quand même un bagage
toutes ces affaires là mais je me dis je
prépare vraiment comprendre quoi les
enjeux puis impliqué là dedans tu
travaillais fort parce que ça me
passionne que juste être en politique
parce que genre jeu paraît très bien en
politique je suis capable d'aider les
bons speech on sait pas quelque chose
que je trouverai qui serait juste pour
les personnes qui se battent dans ce
milieu
puis c'était l'appel amèneront vers à 40
ans je pense pour l'instant c'est
vraiment prendre ma vingtaine parce que
tu reviendras pas juste pour comprendre
qui est qui arrive qu est ce qu il veut
puis quand cette chose d'être réglé
concrètement mais le gym dernière fois
comme j'ai toujours fait dans tout j'ai
fait dans ma vie tu sais c'est cette
passion du sport n'importe quoi tu
plakia n'est pas légale aux choses en
namibie
ce qu'il réalise avec le podcast c'est
elle
reste il va la faire mon bac comprenez
que ça me tentait plus effective j'avais
pu je me trouvais td a rendu la jetée
comme paca pas me concentrer sur toutes
mes tâches scolaires puis je me
demandais ce que je voudrais être
médicamenté ce que je devrais comment
est ce que j'ai si j'aime découvrir ce
manque de concentration et xy
puis après j'ai commencé à faire le
podcast puis à faire pour moi même la
production puis a commencé à 10 heures
de montage puis jetée lakhtine pendant
des heures et des heures puis juste
réaliser ok non tu peux pas un déficit
d'attention c'est juste que tu t'en
crise est qu'est ce que vous voulez puis
dès que tu vas retrouver quelque chose
qui va passionner autant que le podcast
moi que je fais ou n'importe quel avenue
de carrière c'est là que je être capable
de d'atteindre mes objectifs puis je
pense qu'il y ait un conseil je prêt
d'honneur tout le monde c'est juste
vraiment prendre le temps de trouver une
chose qui vont les les envahir puis que
j'avais des jambes viscérale trop
vouloir constamment faire pisser le tu
vas voir on est bord desquels ces deux
succès sur ce serait aussi comment tu
t'es le plus tu le fais le meilleur de
soi est depuis s'était pas de le faire
beaucoup parce que ça t'intéresse pas ce
rejet mais bon puis c'est très difficile
quand tu penses de faire quelque chose
tout le temps si tu n'aimes pas tu vas
voir un mauvais quart d'heure
parce que comme leur vie comme ça se
trouve c'est la beauté notre génération
c'est que je pense pas qu'il va avoir
une carrière qu'on va prendre si je
pense que tout le monde vont s'aligner
pour avoir comme partir à la retraite à
rebours fait 5 6 4 mais ça c'était pour
une certaine génération c'est une fierté
un moyen combien de fois j'ai entendu
des personnes plus âgées dire moi je
passais 41ème place puis jean suffirait
j'entends souvent c'est quand même là
c'est une beauté entend même place mais
il est beaucoup de monde qui vont faire
ceux là n'ont jamais capable moi si vous
savez donc ce sera un début de saison
puis j'ai littéralement fait douze
heures par année je pense même pas
enchaîné du basketball sûrement nuit
justement avoir dû au temps du cje 12ème
que je voulais mais sauf que je suis pas
capable de faire quelque chose longtemps
si j'aime poste et puis je pense que
c'est peut-être un défaut pour c'est
peut-être aller pour ma part parce que
je me dis mon bus comme peut-être ai-je
pas comment tu te décides et puis
peut-être genre ça ça va amener à riez à
long terme et je me dis
moi je vois ça comme juste on processus
continuel essayé de me trouver de
trouver la chose que ça va être assez
clair monsec total à rodez j'étais là je
me disais ce site était sans équivoque
il fallait quelque chose tempère le
c'était clair que cette expérience là
j'en avais besoin même si ça a été
difficile mais ça va améliorer en tant
qu'être humain puis je me dis quelqu'un
qui travaille 40 ans dans la même job
c'est je trouve ces admirables passé
très difficilement même pas des coques
fait quelque chose de super difficile le
genre je te lève mon chapeau
c'est juste que je sais pas si la maison
c'est la chose qui t'a rendu le plus
heureux et je pense des rangs des
aspirations différentes je pense qu'une
autre génération vraiment un besoin que
keller jobs soit soit plus proche où la
passion qui leur job ou six majeur dans
ce sens que l'on dubaï le sentir utile
de santi contribué quelque chose de
sentir valorisé le travail type t'es que
d'autres générations c'était plutôt
l'objectif ce qui est important pour moi
ces souvenirs à ma famille par exemple
spir plus ou si toutes les les le
paysage a changé le ti la stabilité
comme on la connaissait je pense qui est
de la chine en tant que série conseiller
financier peut te dire que par exemple
notre logique est full belle mais la
logique de nos parents est à pied plus
sécure créé le dira pas avoir vu des
milliers de comptes demande tout le
temps je sais pas d'où on va tirer nos
retraites en ce moment notre génération
est pas le concept de retraite va
devenir de plus en plus floue c'est il
va falloir qu'on se trouve des carrières
on veut dire peut-être au point de vue
informatique qu'on va être capables de
faire même si notre corps ne fonctionne
plus la même façon si je sais pas
comment on va opérer bâtir mettons la
situation des ch et celle d'eads en ce
moment mais la meilleure quand on vit en
ce moment notre génération je pense
qu'ils ont sans ligne tout policier h et
celle des parce qu'on veut être capable
de se payer des centres de retraite de
haut luxe si on n'est pas capable de
faire attention
puis de prendre des carrières qui sont
stables comme quelqu'un qui a beaucoup
d'autres
tout ce qu'on peut dire que c'est une
discussion plusieurs que c'est plate
mais la pension ça sort ça rend tout en
continuant sa soeur puis ça va dans
leurs comptes puis après ils savent que
ça va être chaud pour le reste de leur
vie
si je me demande est ce que on est
vraiment c'est ce qu'on a raison c'est
la question alors je pense qu'ils
vraiment est fondamental pour n'importe
quelle génération à ce qu'on fait la
bonne chose on verra le temps de nous le
dire s'est massée sur le tènement si la
recherche de sous dans la finesse man
c'est ça c'est complet c'est
complètement ridicule de se dire que je
peux être heureux
puis la société va faire que au bout du
compte puisque le dollar si longtemps
important c'était il ya un an derrière
leur suma été saganash je poste ce qui
est une crise note okten s'est piqué
keating qui est impliqué ticket qui
milite entre le tp mais qu'habite
répéter watts copine dans le nord où est
soigné par un billet qui mènent leur
conception du bonheur puis du succès
tellement différente de la nôtre
commence la décrirais par exemple si
comme auquel vous l a dit en elle dit
moi j'ai décidé d'arrêter parce que les
mois qui suivent ce qu'elle a déjà été
dit j'ai décidé d'arrêter de parler ma
culture pour aller la vie pierre
décrivez d'aller chez nous sa réserve
me faire ramener par mon oncle puis mes
cousins à pêche et j'ai juste arrêté une
seconde ibos comprend ce qui se passe à
merci
sakho 6 mois c'est celle a dit c est
allé à pêche avec son petit cousin
revenir cuisine et prendre soin des
aînés être ensemble puis elle commande
en parler c'était juste
elle s'est adressée à ce qu'elle
aspirait de pouvoir juste ses pieds mais
temps ci a demandé par rapport aux
droits des autochtones sait ce qu'est ce
qu'elle voulait on dirait dans son
discours c'était juste pouvoir faire ce
puits de laissez nous tranquilles comme
laissez-nous chez nous pour qu'on puisse
continuer à faire le bonheur comme on le
connaît depuis des milliers d'années
c'est fou c'est parce que ici c'est
comme souvent résumée l'hypothèque les
enfants c'est comme c'est quoi le
bonheur le bonheur c'est le succès
militaire c'est comme des quotes-parts
cette fois quand le propriétaire
si tu aimes en faisant les autres sons
sont 12 dans une maison qui pourrit les
murphy sont même pas le sourire qui
montent jusqu'aux oreilles quand même
pas le droit de propriété est même pas
le droit selon la loi la loi sur les
indiens s'est désisté surface hier soir
en chantier puis des parenthèses les
autochtones team et tombale certaine
époque
11e les femmes avaient pas le droit de
voter pour trouve ça aberrant pas dit
voyons qu'il y avait un monde qui existe
et où les femmes avaient pas leur beauté
ou si vous souhaitiez n'est pas un des
exemples est encore à ce jour les
autochtones sont considérés comme des
mineures au nom de la loi puis on pas le
droit de manquer d une terre une maison
ça existe encore dans cinq ans et mère
le manifeste comme tel s'appelle loi sur
les indiens le nom le titre et c'est ce
qui vit dans 5 à la médina à dakar un
jour ça ça va réformer aboli puis il ya
une époque où ce qu'on va dire que je
peux pas croire qu'en 2020 est quitte à
retarder il
et les indiens même paul le guen
histoire soufflera et les maxima ton
molosses je suis justin trudeau le petit
de quel côté l'histoire devrait même
être du bon côté il vraiment et pas fin
c'est là que j'irai à mettons toutes les
personnes qui se questionnent c'est quoi
la bonne action offerts par rapport à
aura 6 puis toute la situation actuelle
sur les réseaux sociaux
moi je dirais qu'il n'ya pas vraiment
une belle chose à faire mais juste soit
conscient que tout ce qui suppose tout
ce que tu poses pas tes enfants
incapables de le voir puis
historiquement parlant les gens vont
être capables de dire de quel côté des
têtes
est-ce qu'il soit capable de regarder
des enfants dans les yeux puis lors du
rookie petits-enfants pour dire moi je
me suis pas levé dans cette situation
quand il y avait tellement justice parce
que à la génération heureux ça m'est
rendu répugnant désagréable ridicule
c'est en ce moment quatre mondialistes
moi ce que je veux et l'abolition au
delà de la fin de l'apartheid mais la
partie est aussi intéressant mais du la
ségrégation aux états unis depuis 50 ans
comme tu peut clairement voir qu'ils
quittaient pour quitter contre puis
certaines de ces personnes là tes grands
parents ce qui peut savoir
ils sont encore là si tu veux faire une
recherche d avoir ils sont où les
racistes dans vie mais pas besoin
d'aller chercher bien loin
j'étais allé voir ce qui se passait dans
ce temps leurs pistes et quoi leur
réunion par rapport à ce qui c'est là
qu'ils maîtrisent pas ce que ton
instagram le ton tout et n'importe quoi
enfin votre capable de voir ils vont
quand même mais pourquoi t'es pas un
carré noir toit en 2020 pendant que
c'est la pandémie avec quoi faire était
de retour un appartement djoua le site
avait pas le temps de mettre au caribou
c'est ça veut pas nécessairement dire
c'est important mais c'est juste tu vas
devoir te justifier apprécié jamais trop
tard pour changer d'idée c'est puissant
c'est important de comprendre si c'est
juste aujourd'hui que tu réalises que
tenait des propos racistes août avait
des préjugés vont muter réalise là que
jamais puis il vaut mieux tu réalises
que tu l'acceptés peu hypocrite le fait
de
dax était changé d'idée 0e pas créés
depuis je pense que du monde qu'est ce
qu'ils doivent comprendre avec le
racisme c'est que le moins tellement
fort parce qu'il ya un visuel de toutes
les atrocités qui ont été faits dans le
passé fait qu'une personne va être ta
cca ce mot là mais si tu comprends que
ce moulin ne veut pas dire que tu es
quelqu'un qui pend du monde la cour
arrière ni que tu peux avoir des actions
raciste sans nécessairement être raciste
puis je mettre là-dedans s'appelle avec
n'importe quel groupe tu veux comprendre
que tu peux échanger ses actions la
pétanque est crue tandis que qu'est ce
que tu fais en ce moment c'est racisme
ou telle mentalité est en ce moment
c'est raciste puis que tu peux te
changer petit améliorée mais là on va
voir un vrai pour regret dans la société
tandis que si tu penses que quelqu'un
qui dise est ce une attaque personnelle
puis tout d'un coup il est en train de
dire que tu es adolf hitler ben là on
veut pas avoir de dialogue parce que
tout d'un coup tout comme ben j'ai deux
amis noirs dans mon primaire
si tu veux prendre les excuses ridicule
comme ça je peux être capable de
dialoguer tout comme auxerre à six
pourquoi la question pourquoi dans la
wilaya pas c'est moi qui la font si
souvent je dénonce et c'est dans
l'argumentation c'est juste ok tu ne
sais pas pourquoi qui dialoguent
dialoguons genre comment pénurie
situation le pis on va avoir des projets
moi je pense que c'est une première
chose c'est justement ce examiner ce
moment se rencontrer ses propres billets
pied moi je vais te donner un exemple ou
moi même j'avais des gros billets
raciste
je m'en suis rendu compte piti le jeu
contre l'histoire j'en suis pas fier
mais je sais c'est juste un exemple
enfin comme tout le monde en est je peux
juger je t'aimais par la méthode redonne
un commentaire je fais québec montréal
tout le temps il s'est dit m
moi je serai québec montréal tout le
temps qu'ils avaient puis je prends des
passages amigo express ce qui pour une
raison toujours de mon gars tu mets
particulièrement beaucoup de d'africains
famille wyss ps be men je te jure je
suis pas fier de le dire mais j'ai honte
mais je n'apparais ou début mai les les
noms à consonance africaine
jetez la joie show qui y voient tartan
jeté le choc et moi je vote à leurs
rendez vous qui va être top albums après
et puis ils vont être perdus qui pore
pisseurs et se retrouve repos puis mène
6-3 mais une fois qu'ils sont arrivés
entre temps ces personnes ces noms à
consonance africaine le jeanneur jamais
mendy avait après une couple de fois je
fais crise mais n'en avait un tas
d'infos king préjugés mon goût mais
depuis c'est correct parce que tu es
cavada parlait justement qui avait
réveillé et si c'est comme le monde qui
veut juste le garder pour eux même si tu
veux pas changer mais c'est pour ça que
ça avance pas la société c'est parce que
c'était pas capable d'admettre des
défauts piron sec comme j'en reviens pas
que c'est moi qui dis ça parce que moi
des quelques scènes le poignant d'un
défaut je suis reçu 71 corps malade
mental mais c'est comme quand tu es
capable de voir des torts un mic gadget
avance plus vite et c'est comme un cost
moi c'était ça mon premier amour ou à
métaux dans le sport basket si je t'ai
foule talentueux mais je voyais tout
temps les choses qu'ils courent je me
disais comme des attaques personnelles
et qu'ils écoutaient pas tant que ça
puisque j'aurais pu m'améliorer
tellement mieux dit je suis content
d'avoir eu cette réalisation là on va
dire à 22 ans puis comme ça je peux
l'appeler dans le reste de ma vie s'est
fait que c'est possible des gens qui
chapeaute que quelqu'un trial regardant
les yeux puis 10 5 est sujette aux
tartes et raciste pour soi les vraies
questions au cepii en même temps at on
pris juge peut comprendre les appliquer
je peux partir on l'a vite chez l'avait
relaxé - titrés à cesser de penser d
comme tout de suite maintenant le fer le
sait vraiment plus une pensée on veut
dire occidentale puis estimé repenser
ses moins bonnes
ça dépend si ces méthodes un jeu pas une
chirurgie après une certaine heure
mathis et d'autres perspectives de la
vie mais ce manque de stress là vaut
peut-être rend plus heureux utilisé pour
ce qui est des personnes répit comme
c'est mon jeu tout en com comme relax
qui sont pas en train de penser
constamment à leur prochain biopic
comment être dans cette situation mais
ça enlève ta mort pour être sur tes
épaules puis au moins d'anxiété et puis
je vous dis c'est extraordinaire qu'est
ce qu'on ferait avec le colti déclinons
j'ai un exemple et c'est tellement
tellement difficile un peu parce que
tout le monde vit ces situations là qui
m'ont par une fois me raconter une
histoire d un de ses meilleurs amis
justement qui appliquée dans roubaud
gouvernement non c'est beaucoup
gouvernement je peux placer où c'est
dans une compagnie vraiment rénommée de
haut niveau au québec il ya pitié dix
fois jamais été pris puis son nom ça
donne qu'il ya un mois mettre dans son
autre vie appliquer tout empire et demi
puis un cv hors pair lé dr
toute l'équipe joe comme accomplissement
du point de changer son nom pour une
joke les ya mis le même séville mais non
québécois le lendemain certains mais
d'appeler puis ça c'est des situations
que vous vous pas les gens je pense pas
nécessairement qui ont réussi dans leur
prise de décision mais c'est juste que
le racisme c'est ça peut être un lieu où
ça pue et juste comme un manque
d'adhérence avec une autre communauté
quittera inconfortable à boire je peux
prendre une bière et gaétan boucher
quelqu'un que tu as dit chez kill or qui
avec bien sûr c'est que c'est mohamed
qui lui viennent le ping pong n'importe
quoi briser le coeur de documentaires
exactement c'était
exemple noté le griller petit prix à la
job il y avait deux flics qualificatif
haut mais on se voyait moins aller
prendre une bière avec le loyer moyen
terme on a moins d'affinités métier men
ouvre toi peut-être différentes cultures
même bien différent parce que tout je
prends de la bière et quelques replis
disent la même chose que toi toujours
autant cessé comme six fois la bière
avec quelqu'un qui veut tout apporter
quelque chose qui veut apprendre de quoi
est à bière est peut-être le plus fort
comme ça dépasse comment tu vois les
différences des gens moi je pense que le
monde différence près 24 notation super
négative une connotation hyper positive
que la différence avec une beauté où ça
peut être quelque chose de méprisables
généralement je vois pas comment une
différence peut être méprisable apporter
quelque chose de différent ce physique
différences d'opinion ben ok puis tu
disais des entrecôtes et d'être capable
d'une facture que de reconnaître ses
torts une fois que c'est aussi ça veut
dire si tu dis quelque chose puis qu'une
personne
une minorité ou une femme quoi que ce
soit at il quelqu'un qui vit des
différentes situations que toi tu te dis
est ce que tu dis ça c'est blessant
tapas choix d'écouter mais oui c'est moi
c'est là que je vois la différence et
dès que c'est quelque chose qui
s'attaque au caractère à quelqu'un ou
quelque chose démotive émotivement
important pour quelqu'un je pense qu'il
faut se mettre ton attention parce que
toutes mes amis vont écouter puis votre
com et quelle idée qui a réduit qu'il
faut écouter les gens qu'il faut pas
l'admettre c'est tant pis pour toi qui
as raison
admettons c'est moi j'admets sûrement
que j'ai comme souvent suborner pitié
quand même je ne sais pas la difficulté
à mettre mes torts métier dès que ça
vient toucher émotivement quelqu'un
c'est là que mon oreille souffre
directement pire c'est qu'il faut les
gens comprennent inclura si c'est que
c'est quelque chose qui purge qui
blessent des gens depuis tant d'années
j'écoutais un podcast la dernière fois
vraiment ridicule que c'est juste des
niaiseries qui se posent tout le temps
mais un certain point on commençait le
podcast avec un speech d'une d'activité
aux etats-unis qui était juste
complètement enragé elle racontait son
background de veepee comment elle disait
que ces malades leur maladie mentale qui
était infligée à notre communauté et
puis que c'était le vécu des choses qui
sont arrivées dans sa vie qu'il a rendue
complètement folle qui attriste piquette
demande l'aide des gens puis je
conduisais j'écoutais puisse épouser
être un podcast signé jeu j'ai commencé
à brouiller avec noël dans mon club
dans mon auto parce qu'ils étaient juste
comme mon dieu j'ai tout vécu c'est même
affaire le puis j'ai juste décidé de
comme fer je vais subir ces choses là
pis ça ça va être comme ça que je vive
ma vitre mais comme vous comprendre
qu'il ya des personnes que ça vient il
chercher ça vient et blessé puis que ça
peut être tellement comme dur
psychologiquement
ben il faut que trouve-t-on aurait un
certain point que tu dises au québec si
je suis blessé pour quelqu'un comment je
peux m'améliorer c'est comme si je vis
dans un monde celui de blessés tout le
monde quitte et sans remords de le faire
mais goodluck de faire apprécier
généralement très puis juste que je
demanderai aux gens c'est juste d'ouvrir
leur aurait pu être prêt dès fois
attendre des affaires comme on peut être
d'accord puis que s'ils ont une bonne
rhétorique s'ils sont bons arguments les
gens peuvent l'écouter puis de mon côté
à ma communauté aussi leur dirai si tu
veux avoir un dialogue tu veux aller
chercher l'appui quelqu'un essaie de le
faire par la compassion par l'empathie
c'est peu de le faire avec les attaques
parce que c'est là que les gens vont
peut-être être capable justement td par
culpabilité sur le vin est en fait qu
ils vont faire quelque chose pour aider
pendant 30 minutes mais que dans deux
moins bons juste encore si 80 des
personas à ce moment l'homme dit à l'afp
je me sentais pas bien qui vous ça me
fait chier big band occasion je te
montre en gb votre contenter mais si tu
viens de chercher une place vraiment
empathique puis vraiment être comme mon
ami j'ai besoin de ton aide s'il te
plaît aide moi c'est vraiment mieux que
genre christ et racisme ça passe par
l'éducation plus que la taxe pour ce que
j'ai c'est pour ce que j'ai un respect
maintenant toi pour quelqu'un qui est
écrit en privé
qui dit hey tu écris ce qui je pense pas
que ça la raison d'être du voici les
raisons plutôt que la personne serait
exposée publiquement des fêtes en impose
publique d'hier ph cet incident est en
grosse pub
voici la preuve pour quelque chose que
tu as fait dans le passé c'est parce que
premièrement justement comme audi tantôt
il jamais trop tard pour apprendre pour
et prend pas me présenter en politique
juste après avoir écrit sur bat il
faudrait être très traque publiquement
ses excuses si c'est ce n'est jamais
trop tard pour apprendre puis c'est
toujours par l'éducation t il y avait
une situation le veulent pas longtemps
puis c'était c'était une personnalité
connue au québec typique avait qui
répètent impose pour contribuer à sa
manière puis le poste avait pas été
appréciée de certaines personnalités
noires t il y avait eu un échange un
message privé depuis
lüthi je peux avoir à la vente qui prend
la défense des pauvres blancs fragile
mais il ya eu une discussion où la
pilule la personne en tant que tel s'est
senti attaqué puis au lieu de dire je
m'excuse des comédies ont été des
frustrés de la pression il y avait mis
ce publiquement je te feras pas les
propos de la personne mais j'ai quand
même un certain malaise avec l'effet de
mettre publiquement parce que la
personne apte s en rendent compte qu'il
faut capter puis entre que je sais pas
qu'est ce que c'est ce que ton opinion
là dessus
moi j'aurai tout le temps n'importe
quand tu te fais attaquer pour quelqu'un
qui est blessé par rapport à une
situation puis qui voudrais-tu disent
quelque chose à sa façon même si t'es
pas d'accord il faut pas que certains
enragent comme premier réflexe parce que
juste 10 est-ce que la souffrance que la
personne vie est plus importante que mon
confort du moment des faits si quelqu'un
puis badoui jesse elle avait pu me
impose comme ça récemment dans qui
parlait de toutes les personnes qui
étaient offusqués qui se faisait
attaquer de tous bords parce qu'il a
fait un pas qui n'est pas représentative
de
vraiment comment changer la situation
pis là j'avais été fier d'une réaction
parce que c'est juste comme crise
réponse de la bonne façon parce que
arrête de penser à ta petite personne du
moment qui se fait blesser parce que
peut pas parler de la bonne façon c'est
son sens tant les plus grandes victimes
de ce ces pauvres et françois blanc qui
présente les personnes qui roulent la
seule fois que j'étais vraiment offusqué
par des personnes qui ont essayé de
genre contribuer mais qu'elle n'a pas
fonctionné c'est quand quelqu'un qui a
fait un post pièce effets de blast et
puis après on est venu me voir dans médi
1 puis est venu me dire à moi ça me
tente plus d'en faire le lit le monde
sont frustrés pis si je peux pas je peux
pas dire quelque chose ils vont tous
temps chez alice avait jamais de parfait
j'étais jusqu'à 21 tensions sont pas
bonnes places malheureusement et puis si
juste et qu'en même temps on peut
vraiment aider parce que comme ton
premier réflexe devrait être comme au
québec où j'ai d'europe exact merci men
s des plaisirs guez jaser ils ont
vraiment fait plaisir d'être venu pour
vrai j'adore que vous faites ça
m'inspire foule pour vrai ça me donne la
motivation justement puisque donné dans
dans l'univers des podcasts moi je vois
c'est juste comme personnellement au by
cécile se rendre à vis de ceux en sort
grandie soirée chimène tout technique à
le rencontrer mais n'était pas vrai mais
la fin est ce que est ce que tu 5
est ce que tout ce que le mouvement ce
moment if they dessus voyons comment
formule afin de susciter dessus excité
par pete tout adventures fois où tu dis
parce que la sma
on le sent déjà un certain
ralentissement c'est normal je sais ça
pourra pas rester à tous les jours tout
le monde parle que de ceux pour
l'éternité
est ce que tu penses que savoir je vois
des effets profonds sur le long terme je
suis très fier
mes frères caucasien ce moment pour de
vrai parce que je trouve que peu importe
la durée du mouvement
je pense qu'il ya eu un déclic de
compréhension que maintenant si
quelqu'un porte l'association racistes
ils vont se rappeler de ce moment là
dans l'histoire ils vont tous tendre
comme est ce que c'est vrai est-ce que
la situation puis sur des moments
concret peut-être ça va ça pitié est-ce
qu'il va avoir un gros mouvement
révolutionnaire qu'on va mettre les lois
au québec que ça va pouvoir donner une
égalité concrète au point vue législatif
pour la communauté noire
je pense pas je pense pas aux titres
même si aussi sur un peu plus bruyant ce
moment mais je pense que le fait que du
monde a compris certaines choses vont
beaucoup éliminer des réactions des
petits moments qu'on a vécus dans notre
vie de tous les jours que j'en sais pas
bien pour un noir ou 19h de même qu'ils
t'ont tant pis j'ai après afin de
contraindre à prendre même si les fesses
comme ça qu'on a entendu ce très souvent
dans une vie
en ce moment je pense que les gens ont
compris un gros concept qu'est le
racisme
je pense que nous devons essayer de
changer de façon graduelle
mais sauf que c'est mieux que juste
penser qu'il ya pas de problème pour moi
où est-ce qu'on ne suit pas ce qu'on
écoute toi ce que tu suivais ça vous
temps de m'écouter plus bas n'est pas
sûr que suivre au poste intéressant